We're live guys.
Oh,
is it live?
Yeah.
Oh,
cool.
And we're live.
Ladies and gentlemen wanted a picture quick.
We're here with the great and powerful Jimmy Smith.
Welcome to the UFC.
Jimmy Smith,
thank you so much for,
she'll be here officially official.
We wanted to talk about it last time we'll do on the podcast,
but we have dance around it.
You,
it's so many people wrote me were like,
Joe,
really?
Here I'll go,
hey man,
Joseph pro.
But he uh,
you hinted well we danced around it quite a bit.
Nobody know what he totally knew and of course the great and powerful 80 Bravo.
Yo Yo yo.
Brian counts on the way,
but he's bringing wine and cheese.
He insists on wine and cheese.
He thinks he's had some sucking fucking cocktail party.
We're going to compare scripts.
That's Brian.
He's gotta have his wine and cheese.
Uh,
do Ho choice versus a Jeremy Stevens is the main event.
If you've never heard of one of these podcasts before,
this is a fight companion podcast,
which means we're going to watch the fights.
Most likely we'll talk about the fights,
but we might not,
we can talk about whatever the fuck.
Like Eddie and I have,
we've gotten through the entire podcast.
We never talked about the fight until like the last round of the main event,
but Missouri,
Missouri Division of perfect.
Oh,
there in Missouri was the Saint Louis.
That's what it is,
right?
Yeah.
The,
and they haven't adopted the AVC rules.
That's important for the judging at least.
Damn sure.
They haven't adopted those in Nevada,
which is real weird.
Crazy.
Look how good Michael Johnson looks at 45 Eddie was saying that it's racist to
say that,
but I don't think it is like got shredded.
He is fantastic.
Yeah.
That's a good weight class for him.
I think,
you know,
it's just,
there was a beep number.
Go Madoff's,
those giant 50 fives they could just grapple fuck you and beat your brains.
And he had enough of that monsters.
Yeah.
It's like that's,
that's about enough of this way class when people remember how much the other
guy talked to Dana white while he was beating my assets.
That's bad.
And he's a great fighter and that's what's so funny about it is,
well this was supposed to be the main event on the prelims,
but Uriah hall and Vito Belfort fell out really unfortunately,
which is a fucking bummer.
Apparently Uriah hall was like on death's door trying to make weight,
but he had like gotten sick.
I had heard during training he was having some real issues.
He said his body shut down about three weeks out.
A lot of people out here dealing with that fucking flew and then Robert Falls
just coach died.
Who's a great guy by the way,
if you ever met Robert,
he was fantastic,
but you don't meant it was just going through a lot of stress.
Yeah.
And that'll,
that'll kill your cut to yeah.
Robert,
um,
killed themselves.
Yeah.
So did his brother.
It's such a,
such a pump.
That guy's a nice fucking,
God loved us.
Such a good dude.
It's such a bummer man.
Yeah.
I'm so instead this fight,
which was going to be on the prelims.
I'm excited about this fight though because Darren Elkins is some sort of a
different kind of human.
That guy takes fucking punishment.
Like nobody,
Eddie probably looking for marijuana.
No,
no,
it's okay.
We don't know we can this,
this is a free,
we live
in California.
I don't drink anymore and at all.
Nope.
No more drinking.
Wow.
And no more caffeine.
I'm on intermittent fasting.
Dan.
You look good dude.
Your face looks good.
Split.
I'm not giving this away.
Yeah,
I don't give that away.
Oh,
I made a giving it up.
Sorry.
Giving it up.
Who still don't give it up.
Don't give it away.
So,
uh,
how long has it been since the booze?
I,
I decided initially that I would only allow myself to drink like a by data set
somewhere or if I did,
um,
you know,
I,
my,
at the 10th Planet Holiday Party,
I allowed myself to drink,
but that was the last time.
It's been about a month and a half since I'm in a drink.
Interesting.
How you feel?
I feel great.
Like it.
I don't need alcohol.
No,
you don't need alcohol.
It just gets you in trouble.
It makes you say shit no more Indian.
Oh,
India.
The Indians out now he's smoking the peace pipe.
Yeah.
No more Indians.
Jimmy Smith,
you spoke the reefer every now and then.
Every puff just to celebrate.
Yeah.
But the thing to me is,
is uh,
little known personal fact.
I've never had a drink in my life ever,
ever mine.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So what the fuck do you blame your Mc fuck ups on?
Nothing.
I have no excuses for my behavior.
That's terrible.
None.
Well,
you know,
you've been hitting the head of gang.
I have been hit in the head.
Yeah.
That,
that's more than once.
Yeah.
Speak,
speaking to hit in the head.
The world title,
Steve Bay and Francis,
they're showing the preview for it right now.
Good fucking me.
Fantastical,
Glee.
Mooglie I've never been more excited for a heavyweight title fight ever.
That's a freak.
Oh,
he's a freaking stir.
The freakiest.
He's a one in a million athlete.
Like if you think there's 320 million people in this country,
how many in Ganas are there?
If there's 300 I'd be fucking stunned.
I don't even think he's,
I think it's more than one in a million.
Like the guy who's built like that,
Susan,
it's been training three years or something.
There's probably a whole shot.
Five years.
Five years total.
I was homeless five years ago.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
Crazy dude worked in a sand mine as a kid,
like goddamn character and to Robert E.
Howard comic book,
like digging sand as it can already.
That's a hero cone and by the way guys did.
You're not a comic book Dork.
Just growing and with his anger is pushing that thing right?
Schwartzenegger pushing the,
the,
we log the wheel forever.
The grinder.
I mean,
what better workout is there for?
A young guy wants a beat the fuck out of people than digging sand all day.
Just carrying sand all back and legs and arms.
I mean,
think about how much strength is required.
Just fucking dig sand all the time.
There's places that are,
they're called sandbox workouts or something like that.
Have you heard about those?
Maybe they start Doug on that,
but he hadn't gone.
Who opens up a chain of Sam training or something like that.
But we were just talking about before,
before we got on headset.
Um,
guys who are comfortable,
who have money,
who have another crew,
have a fallback.
It's hard to be 100% committed.
This dude was digging sand homeless.
You're never more committed to winning.
If I don't win,
I don't eat man.
And that motivation so strong,
as powerful as most powerful thing in the world when it comes to fighting.
The crazy thing about that dude is he has so much to learn.
Still five years of MMA training.
I mean,
his ground game is very rudimentary.
He's just trying to stuff take downs.
He's freakish strong,
he's got real good training.
He's at the UFC performance institute,
so he's training with real good guys on a daily basis.
But man,
I mean a lot to lot to grow.
He's there all the time.
Yeah,
he lives there.
Practically.
Look out shredded Michael Johnson as Jesus Christ.
He's fucking shredded at 45 and gone fought Fabi sword though.
No,
no,
no.
He fought our Lawsky and then he knocked out Overeem and then they said,
you got it,
you got the title shot.
When he put over him in orbit,
everybody was like,
okay,
the this is the only fight to get what he wants to say.
That's awesome.
I mean,
who the fuck is and what a story and Steve Bay's run has cleared out a lot of
guys.
It's just that he,
you know,
you need that fresh face,
you need that knockout guy and then steep based chasing history.
Those things come together.
Some of the crazy thing,
the history is only two title defenses and the entire history of the UFC
heavyweight division.
It's only been defended twice.
No one's ever done it three times.
And then nuts.
And that's the first title.
First title was heavyweight.
Yeah.
Think about that.
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
Yeah.
Michael Johnson shred it.
He's going to fuck a 36 pack.
There's a lot of jealousy in your face.
Can you see?
Can they see?
Well,
admiration and maybe a bit of want.
I want to have abs like that,
but I wouldn't say jealousy.
I'm happy.
I'm happy to drop cause I was felt he was a little soft at 55 I always felt like
he should have looked like this,
you know?
I mean this dude's lean is fuck and he hits so hard and he's so fast.
I think at 45 it's going to be a monster.
I think this is a big move for him.
I'm a big fan of this guy,
man.
He hurting her MCHA Madoff in that fight too and he's the first guy to put
neuroma comin off in trouble.
People Forget.
He Starts Justin Pour,
Yay k owed him.
Michael Johnson's a bad motherfucker.
The problem when you get in there with a guy like Norma Madoff and he beats your
ass that bad,
you're like,
well how the fuck am I ever going to beat this guy?
Yeah.
You know like this doesn't move you.
Every,
every major move,
most major moves in MMA or due to a beat down there due to usually getting
manhandled by somebody who's naturally without weight class or big for that way.
Because if it's not a move that way,
it's a move to a do camp.
It's like I got to train for Asa Hobby or go to Matt Hume or go to one of the
wizards.
Someone was going to revamp my shit.
You see a lot of that,
you know,
but it's often times too late.
It's such a crazy fucking sport because while you're training for a,
you kind of have to be trained in for the fight.
You can't really take too many chances and learn too much new shit that's,
you don't,
when you talk to trainers,
oh,
the old school guys,
that's one of the things they say about Mike Tyson is he fought so much,
he didn't develop enough.
He just wasn't in the gym that much.
He was fighting every,
you know,
twice a month in his prime when he was younger.
So here we go for (525) 145-0440 nine of the first round for trying to sync it
up.
Michael Johnson and Darren Elkins and Darren Elkins there.
Here's a guy who made a big move when he went to Alpha male.
It's made a huge impact on him and he looks way more polished,
way,
way smoother.
The way he moves.
He really saw that in the Bursa,
Beck Dick Fight.
That was a crazy fight because that was a fight where he was way underdog,
like a by a big margin for a good reason.
And you,
he's heard already getting hurt.
Yeah,
he's getting tagged.
We'll see Michael Johnson goes after him before he stays patient.
I always think whenever I see a guy at 35 45 from Alpha Male,
I always think,
Ooh.
When they called them and go,
well,
we need to get a 45 for you to get that call.
You gotta be Beasley because they have a lot of those guys.
I mean,
that's their whole team.
Oh,
Michael Johnson.
Just tapping him again.
He's fast man at 45 very fast and he's range.
He's getting good extension on his punches.
Yeah.
And at 45 is going to be enjoying that even more.
Good height reach of Ed.
She just looks perfectly built for the way class.
Any as a speed.
A lot of people don't realize when you drop a weight class,
those guys are a hell of a lot faster and he has the speed to keep up with those
guys.
A lot of them don't.
Yeah.
And I think he's probably going to be even faster at 45
although he dang,
I serve 10 leg went out on him.
Oh,
this is a good fight already.
we tagged them again.
The Elkins hasn't really figured it out.
He's waiting on him.
Well,
he's just a step slower for sure.
And just not,
not nearly as smooth as Stryker.
Elkins relies on his ability to take tremendous punishment and his heart and his
endurance,
or it just never stops at this pace.
And if you start to slip,
Ooh,
sweet.
Left to prom is,
that's a tough thing to rely on in this business.
The Way MMA isn't it?
Oh,
I'm a tough guy.
Well,
welcome to the club.
It's like 500 tough guys in the UFC.
Tough
Shit.
We got tough girls.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
Fucking Holly Holm.
How about that fight?
Wow.
Amount of punishment that she took against Cyborg.
Crazy.
She give cracked.
So Eddie Bravo.
That's it for now.
For,
for,
for alcohol.
That's it.
I think that's a good move,
man.
I'm happy for you.
Thank you.
It was doing nothing for him.
Then what prompted you,
if you don't mind me asking,
was there something that prompted,
it was just like,
oh no explaining.
Just found myself going every night.
The same thing.
I get home
after training and I'll have a glass of wine and watch some Netflix and there's
been a lot of great shows lately,
so I've been finding myself drinking like three,
four times a week.
And um,
then,
you know,
I go to the airport and I'm bored.
I'll have a couple of glasses of wine and then it just,
just one day I thought,
man,
I'm turning into an alcoholic over here.
What's going on?
I was,
I was drinking because I was bored,
so I thought too old for that shit man.
You know what I mean?
It's just bad for your body man.
It's just,
yeah,
there's no need for it.
I like a glass of wine with a meal,
but every time I've gotten drunk,
the next day I've just been disappointed with myself.
Oh Shit.
Brian counts your ladies and gentlemen with wine and cheese,
like some sort of a party.
How you doing man?
I know Jimmy.
Jimmy Smith just met.
Very nice to meet first time La la La.
Do we need a wine bottle opener here?
Oh eight he doesn't drink anymore and I don't drink any.
This only half done this side of the table doesn't drink.
We just got to watch you get hammered drunk.
Ever handle red wine anymore?
I'm getting older,
but I got some good red wine.
Jesus Christ.
Everybody's complaining about getting older,
not being able to handle boots.
We're watching Darren Elkins and Michael Johnson here.
It's in the first round and so far Michael Johnson's looks smooth as butter.
255 pounds.
Bam.
That left hand's finding a home.
Oh look,
it's taken on the chin though.
Elkins still in it now once again,
this is one of those may be ABC.
It's ten eight non ABC probably go ten nine.
They haven't adopted new rules.
Do you think that would be ten eight though?
It could be.
I'm thinking,
I'm not saying it is.
I'm saying with the new rules that they're just a lot more common man.
It's,
I think the actual rule in please someone out there.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
Uh,
if someone,
clearly if they went to aspects of the fight who he just hit him with another
left him and he's certainly landing the significant strikes and he's the
aggressor.
Yeah.
So you could certainly has a clear advantage and I would like to see rounds like
that.
But Jimmy,
I think we need a better score system.
I think the 10 point system from boxing is goofy.
I just don't think we need it.
I think we need like a hundred point score system that takes into account
submission attempts,
take down attempts,
defense takes that into account,
leg kicks,
knees,
elbows,
punches,
all those things quantified.
The impact of those techniques,
how hard they're hitting,
how close to choke is,
how close the arm bar is,
how good the defense is.
You know like all those things should be taken into consideration and I think we
should have more than three judges.
I think you have a three judges is fucking foolishness.
Why three people?
I think there you have way more of a likelihood of having some bullshit decision
if there's only three people.
I think if you have 20 experts like or people online little cheese,
what cheese buddy?
Got to keep talking.
I'm listening.
20 experts.
Maybe you know how many,
maybe even open up to people online like have a select few people wisdom of the
crowd.
How about a problem that you really respect?
How bout knockout
only MMA,
right?
A lot of people die.
There's no points,
no points,
no judges.
And if it goes the distance and there's still not a knock out,
they get each,
they get a cold,
cocky,
try the back and forth until someone gets mad.
Rabo wants us to go back to ancient Rome,
basically cold cock,
like a slack,
a soccer match.
I always felt like he's crazy.
That free kick at the end of it.
It's hard to get.
How cool would that be?
Knock out,
only come on and be so ridiculous.
Watch it,
wouldn't you?
Yeah.
I would watch to see in that game in Afghanistan where they hold back on teams
and they've essentially have a goat,
a dead goat and the this side and they played with whips and the side that can
get the goat into the goal is the winner.
Wins,
gets to take down.
The horses die in that game.
Oh,
and goats.
I'm sure.
Plenty of goats as well.
Dead.
Wow.
Elkins.
With the take down here,
this changes things.
We're going back to this goat thing way we're going,
I know this is the exciting part,
but I want it was Darren till it first.
Oh,
Hammer fist by Elkins here.
Yeah.
He goes,
come on quick.
Dylan.
Who Elkins does all right.
First,
how can I watch fight in the UFC forever and you get to compare him to till till
I got here.
I'm saying it's fake.
It's like Brian.
Yeah.
How dare you?
I don't know
Darren till Tila fucking fight.
Jesus Christ.
He's scary.
He is geared was just walking a cowboy fan.
I was just watching it.
Do you know Vinny shoreman a lot this week.
Oh,
I'm sure he like,
you know,
I watch UFC all the time,
but there's a huge,
and you're watching fights and studying fights and I had been studying.
That's what I'm supposed to do basically all night tonight I'm here.
I was thinking when I knew that you got the Gig,
I was like,
like if I had a call bell tour I'd be fucked.
Yeah.
Like I,
I just,
there's too many people.
I don't know who the fuck.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Jimmy,
you want a little manchego cheese?
I would love some cheeses.
That's fantastically cheese when he won't drink your fucking,
I'll have cheese.
It looks like he's in shape.
I'll tell you that much.
Which one?
Elkins or no,
I'm talking about Jimmy Hill.
His shape.
Kids got some arms on him.
He's a Jujitsu black person has a plan for real black belch.
Poor,
Huh?
Yeah.
I went back to training this week.
Really?
For the first time.
Crucifix.
Look at this mounted crucifix for Elkins.
Oh,
okay.
Look at this.
Elkins gets the back.
Three minutes to go.
Oh Shit.
Magic Elkins spoils the big hundred 45 pound party from Michael Johnson would
not be the first time.
It would not be the first time.
You can't fucking sleep on this guy's such an animal.
He has a better body though,
so,
oh dammit.
Oh Shit.
Huh?
How'd that happen?
Oh Shit.
Go to sleep.
Oh Wow.
Fucking savage.
God Damn.
That dude's a savage.
Took the punches and came back,
man.
Holy Shit.
Daren.
Darrin Elkins is fucking savage.
Whew.
He got teed off on in the first one.
I didn't want to come back.
Yeah.
Bryan,
you,
you missed the the teen off part.
This finish so extraordinary.
It's area can't count this guy out.
He's just such a fucking mutant.
He's such an animal.
Look at this.
Takes the back.
How I was like,
oh I didn't want to get too excited.
I was like,
yeah he got his back but I don't want to get too excited here.
Is this going to get crazy?
That was a high level move cause some people would have jumped on the back and
kind of just volunteer to it.
Like a be a backpack.
Yeah.
But he pulled them back.
That's it.
That's a high level move right there.
What do you mean?
Oh he didn't jump on him.
He pulled you into his hips.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cause you just to get too high because people,
sometimes people when they jump on the back,
they want to be on the back but on top and they're trying to force being on the
back on top.
But it's way easier just to pull them back and you're on their back.
But you're on your back as well.
Some people feel uncomfortable there cause if they spin now they're on your
guard.
But if you have a high level rear naked choke,
you just take the easy route,
pull them back and just finish him off your back finishing.
Very hard thing to defend against.
Cause I see a lot of guys who would defend for a long time look at the hips if
they show it again when he had his hips all the way in and when I was,
that stretches your core out.
And so it's interesting.
You also can't,
you can't curl up and protect your neck and you had the bottom triangle on the
wrong side.
He had the body triangle on the bottom.
He's still schools she could hold.
Can he keep it?
It works for some people don't need a switch it.
Yeah.
Some people can really hold that thing.
Well I think for him it was just like he had it,
he's arching his back.
He had it locked in.
He wasn't going to give up that spot and try to switch legs.
Fuck,
that's amazing.
Guys are getting really good at spinning inside of body triangles.
There's,
there's,
there's technique to that really.
Yup.
What do you do?
Um,
if you can get there choking arm on the other side,
like in a baseball grip,
like I got your left arm on the right side and which side is the body triangle
on?
It doesn't matter.
Now you just got to really focus on putting your shoulders on the mat and you're
controlling his arm.
Okay.
And then you slowly inch by inch you turn your hips and
he's still as the body triangle on,
but inch by inch you're holding the wrist and you're turning around boom.
And then one big explosion and you're in the guard to holding the two on one on
the arm,
the choking arms big.
Yes.
That's huge.
And otherwise he's going to be all over your neck.
When you do that,
you freeze them to somebody who was going to come up with a technique to beat
that or to try to mitigate that.
Well,
the technique really and not letting it happen in the first place
because in the very beginning,
in the very beginning of 10th planet,
like right away I was so into body triangles and doing dsfs I wouldn't,
it's,
it's uh,
just a neck crank.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
But uh,
but calm,
deep south.
But when,
anytime I would put on a body triangle,
I wouldn't even think about a rear naked choke anymore.
I was like,
that's too hard.
I'm just going to get on my side,
puts you on your side and just connect my hands around your head somehow anyway.
And then I fall forward and I crush it.
The [inaudible] old move on.
Remember beast.
Yes.
Peace.
Never rear naked choke anybody.
He'd always get to the back,
put a body triangle on and go d sab on him.
He didn't even know how to do a rear naked choke.
He had,
he had gaping holes in his game anyways.
Anyways.
Um,
what ended up happening was we were all about by triangles in the beginning and
there were so dangerous.
Like if someone put a body trying on me,
I know I'm done.
If,
what if all you think about as a neck crank instead of the rear naked choke,
you just focus on the DSM.
You don't need a rear naked choke.
It's,
it's Dunsky.
So in the very beginning,
the first defensive move when someone takes your back is,
oh it was always,
don't let them put the Goddamn body triangle on.
That was the first move.
That's everybody's first move.
Don't let it get if he's got one,
if he's got your back,
don't let him get the hook.
So he has one hook.
Don't let them get two hooks.
That'd be puts both hooks.
You Bet.
And I let them put a body triangle in
your nest.
Of course,
of course.
But there's things you do.
Like what?
What,
which ended up doing is as soon as someone takes your back,
you put him in like a reverse quarter guard,
you,
you trap one of his legs and you'd escape from that.
That way there's no body triangle ever going to happen.
So if that is the,
your first move,
it's in your DNA where someone takes you back and you take his leg out the mix.
Cause you're already worried about that body triangle.
Then the body trying was become very hard to get really,
really hard.
So when the guy who's back has been taken,
if that is his focus on stopping that,
it's very hard to put it in.
So what ended up happening for 10 planet is we went away from the body triangles
cause I saw the damn,
I'm not going to focus all this time on the dsfs when um,
there's going to,
most of the time we're not even getting the body triangle.
So we got to focus on a rear naked chokes with just the leg hooks and just like
Marcella Garcia.
So we shifted away from the body triangle and I wanted everyone to focus on just
good old fashioned traditional rear naked choke with both hooks in and get re
really good from there.
And the body trying on the [inaudible] that's like extra,
don't rely on it.
But what ended up happening is everyone's defensive first defensive move.
Um,
didn't,
it wasn't attack,
put up a tack one of uh,
his legs and put it in reverse quarter garden.
We went away from that because that was the,
wasn't
there anymore.
Do you follow me on my losing?
You know,
I understand what you're saying.
So niche,
that just shows how complex Jujitsu is and you're constantly having to make
these adjustments and [inaudible] we're going way back because of Ebi overtime,
but we start guys on their back and are shootout over time round.
The game has grown so much just from getting good at those rounds.
Just spending a lot of time at dissecting the authentic,
the arm bar position and the rear naked choke the,
did you considered any other positions that you would allow people to do other
than those two?
Those two are good enough.
That event people would,
will suggest,
why don't you go have a Mt.
One or just nice and super crazy basic.
Something that everyone could agree on.
If you're going to have a shootout in Jujitsu,
it's gotta be naked Choker Armbar.
That's it.
Yeah.
In other words,
you can't start there.
You start there so much back and over time and over time.
You know what spider web is like.
You get a guy in [inaudible] position,
you hook one of the arms and he's defending.
Okay guys defending it.
But you have the arm bar and he's going to start from there.
You got rid of him hooked and the back is,
we start with a seatbelt in with two leg hooks and you're sitting on your
button.
We start right there and go,
ready,
go.
Have you seen combat Jujitsu?
No.
Dude,
Eddie Bravo came up with the greatest idea of all time combat Jujitsu.
It's regular Jujitsu,
but you get to smack the shit out of each other.
So they're open palm start like it's similar,
but it's only on the ground.
It's only when it goes to the ground.
So on the ground,
well a Wagner roadshow,
right?
Was that neurogenesis?
The first guy to stop a guy that way?
Tkl and Jujitsu and he's using his palms like boss route and use doing pancreas.
Just fucking dropping them down,
slamming him home.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it opens up,
it makes Jujitsu more realistic because there's certain positions that you are
so exposed and if the guy smacks you in the head,
it smacks you in the nose and smacks you in the eyes.
You're just not going to stay in that spot or you can.
There's got to be guys that are training smacks.
They're going to get really good at it.
Guys are going to be able to take guys out.
What smart.
Yeah.
Most of them,
99.9% of the guys that are down for combat.
You did.
So I got a long list of people wanted to,
all of them have MMA experience.
Only one guy.
Only one Guy Bennati one of my brown belts.
He,
he's the only dude who never even thought of MMA.
Never even thought of it.
And he wanted to do because his guard is probably top three in the world.
I've never seen anything.
We talked about him last podcast with the Hindu Lo tiene Benetti,
you know,
so,
um,
he's the only one and he got,
he went against Wilson Hayes who had in combat Jujitsu.
He's automatically rank number one.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Legit black belt
fought Demetrius Johnson,
possibly the greatest fighter ever.
You know what I mean?
Now he's,
he was in combat Jiu Jitsu and he went against Ben ended though because I
watched the,
in
Austin,
I was one of the color guys,
you know,
it was fun and I didn't know what I was looking at it as much,
but you know,
obviously because I don't know enough about it,
it was on it invitation.
It was so incredible because I watch those guys and I'm telling you from my
untrained eye,
I couldn't even see when they were tapping the dude's like they were doing
things.
It didn't,
it looked like he was doing nothing.
And I was like,
what happened?
What do you get them on?
I didn't know what a tap modern,
I couldn't figure it out and then,
but,
but the one thing I noticed that pure Jujitsu practitioners,
those competition guys who are amazing,
they can do things there.
They there because there's zero striking.
It's true that you get an,
you get in very bad habits.
Have you ever tried to get into an MMA fight?
Well,
you see that a lot of times you used to see that more often with leg locks,
right?
Guys go for leg locks and they'd be in a weird position and they'd get smashed
go,
uh,
old school,
Ian Freeman and Frank Mir.
Remember that?
That was like one of the first times that happened.
Tim Silvia Cafe Dante was,
there was another one
whose deeper,
which one was,
which one is deeper there.
They might be the same,
same historical,
same historical genre,
but it was,
it was a less popular fight much Les Paul,
I love capital.
Why aren't,
why aren't so,
so,
um,
leg locks are not used as much because you are,
you can get punched in the face.
No,
it's almost always giving up position to get a leg lock are almost always
sitting back.
Okay.
To get a leg so I can sit up and punch your head through the ground.
It's also,
you're always,
you're committing your legs and two arms usually to elect,
defend yourself.
Guys are just punching you in the face while you're doing that.
And then Ian Freeman fight.
Ian Freeman,
uh,
was locked up in a heel hook and frank mir was cranking on his heel and Ian just
steps in and just starts crying,
get him off his job.
Hanson Romina Sato is a great one too.
Yeah,
that was an amazing one.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
There's been a gang of,
those were guys we're over committed.
Yeah.
And we had to learn,
I mean,
the risky,
risky,
yeah.
But the,
the state of the leg lock game these days is way different than those guys that
were trying to pull off leg locks back then.
Even Romina Sato even that level,
he was considered one of the best leg lockers back then.
But the level today and leg locks is way beyond that.
It's,
yeah,
it's way beyond what the guys at a DDS have done.
I mean,
they've taken the leg lock game.
I mean it's,
it's beyond sambo
DDS be catch wrestling.
Donna,
her death squad,
Don John,
John Danaher.
He'll be here.
John will be here tomorrow at 8:00 AM.
Oh,
he will?
Yeah.
We're doing a podcast early.
Did you have you?
I was talking to chill about the last Abu Dhabi and he told me a story.
I was laughing my ass off.
He said they did the rules meeting and they said,
well we're not from anybody,
so no controversies.
You want three distinct taps and every goes,
I need to walk out of here.
You don't like what we're talking about.
You don't have time to do this.
That is,
he'll
hook.
Even even three of these,
your ACL,
everybody looked at each other like we're all agreeing to not do that.
Like all the people were like,
okay,
if I tap,
let me go dude,
fuck this rule.
Shit.
Let me go.
And Yeah and Charles like I got caught and I just went and the guy let me go.
But like he goes,
cause it can just destroy your need for why everything in your knee will go
everything cause just,
Ooh,
it's so bad,
so bad.
I've seen a horrible shit.
I've seen dudes get their shoulders wrecked with Camorra's.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Yeah.
No,
it's all true.
It's all true.
True.
But I'm saying I know where you're coming from with the leg lock thing.
People have gotten
lots of wow man,
he was not as common as you barely whoa.
Well you know though,
it's good to see him out of the wheelchair is recovering.
I don't,
ah,
he,
he got hit by a train man,
which is crazy.
I mean most people would be dead.
It makes me want to cry.
Fuck,
fuck.
Wow.
It's great that he's him going,
fuck,
look at a walking that's just going to come back
warrior together.
And the last thing he said to me,
we had a scene together and uh,
it was this,
a week later he got hit.
He said,
um,
he goes,
I hope I can put my shoes on when I'm older.
I fucking waste.
Oh yeah man,
it's good to see him and Dana hugging it out.
A lot of guys,
a lot of guys think that was,
he was worried about,
he was talking about head trauma.
He said he worries about it,
you know,
and then he gets hit by a train of,
Oh,
you should man,
everybody should fucking worry about it.
I mean it's something that has to be taken in consideration.
I mean it is what it is.
Yeah.
But fuck yeah,
he's a good guy.
He is good.
He's a very good guy and a one the most important figures in the history of
sport.
When you break down what he was,
he represented like a powerful wrestler that embrace submissions whenever we
call it that far side arm bar and George St Pierre,
he was one of the first guys.
It was like a real strong wrestler that had very high level submission skills.
He was a huge leap in the sport.
Yeah.
I mean he beat hoists.
Gracie on the ground.
I took this dash.
He was one of the first
like,
like top level athletes,
you know what I mean?
Like a stud athlete.
Yeah.
I had,
there were a lot of the guys for it that way.
Well,
I'm glad he's okay and it's nice to see him walking around getting man.
All right,
so we're going to go to [inaudible] in a meal Mech.
I love this fight too.
Nobody wants to fight Huseman nobody.
He said,
everybody's running from that dude.
That guy is a smashing machine.
I mean he is a fucking tank of a human being.
But this a meal met guy talk about um,
leg locks.
He got his way into the UFC by knocking out Tokyo.
He uh,
he smashed him and some other organization.
He fighting the fall holiday.
Yeah,
that's a mailman.
Amil Mac is a,
the the crazy viking guy.
He's a star fucking animal.
His,
he's so shredded.
It's stupid.
But Kamara Uzman top of the food chain wrestler,
Super Athlete,
just a tank of a man who everybody's running from just running from,
nobody wants a piece of him.
When you talk about like top 10 guys,
he's the guy that nobody's mentioning.
There's,
there's a special thing I think in MMA combat sports period is there are guys
who are great and then there are guys who are frightening when we're nobody in.
Another good example is,
is Tokyo yours rather than when he was a fringe top 10 guy or you know,
eight people were like,
I don't want anything to do with that dude.
I don't want to be anywhere near like I'd rather have,
I'd rather have a GSP who's better but won't hurt me,
like to Kenya will rip your leg in half and just have no idea what he's doing.
Man,
I feel like scary dude.
He did some bad things in the EOC,
definitely held on submissions,
but I feel like he got a bad deal when he got fired.
When he got kicked out of the UFC.
The submission that he held,
I watched it and I say that was not egregious and that was a normal thing for
anybody else.
Yeah,
it certainly wasn't,
certainly wasn't his worst.
It's just,
it was like the fourth time that they had said,
hey,
don't,
the other ones were horrible.
Other ones were worse,
but it was just,
it was a straw.
To me it was scheels fight was like fucking crazy and I thought the refereeing
and that was terrible.
Crazy.
That was in world series of fighting out in his eyes.
He was literally in his eyes and show respect for him.
When Yan shields look,
the wrapping was like duty keeps gouging.
Mine is I afterwards,
I think I would've been a crazy amount of what you have to then he held onto the
Camorra.
It's tough.
It's tough to under.
Yeah.
And then Jake,
Jake hit him after he went to Kamora cause he wouldn't let go of the Camorra.
But if you go back,
and I mean I'm not giving the guy in excuse,
but you want to find out about his childhood.
His childhood was horrific.
He was working on a farm when he was like a little boy.
He has a giant scar in his chest because he got slashed open and they just tried
to like tape it up on,
glue it together.
They never brought him to the hospital.
I mean,
he would literally would eat pig slop like you had no food and just worked on a
farm.
It was,
you know,
and then as he got older,
made his way into Rio and then found Minataro school and started learning
Jujitsu and just a tank from far more from being a boy having to work.
And he's a fighter and God,
no,
he's this,
he's scared as well as scary.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean a kid that's grown up in that horrific environment like that,
who knows what kind of,
who knows who you see suffered and all that stuff,
but definitely was in danger and fearful from the time he was very young and it
was in a position where he was struggling for his life,
like for survival in a way that week because we don't understand.
We don't understand what's so soft.
He might have,
no,
he obviously probably as impulse control,
all kinds of issues.
It's an animal and a lot of ways,
but like if you look at the Avalon fight that he had it and Abu Dhabi where
they're rolling out and he's holding on to a heal hook.
Oh,
it was horrible.
Like the ref stop,
stop,
and he won't stop.
Yeah.
And Avalanche freaking out.
But then there's also that terrible situation when they restarted them with heal
him and it was done.
But you never can do,
you can't,
particularly with heel hooks.
No,
you cannot say ready,
set,
go.
Because you got to assume
that the guy's securing that in the middle of a scramble.
You gotta be in motion.
There's also,
you can't just start him because he's going to rip it.
But the thing was about the,
the mental state is,
you know,
they stop and Evelyn is furious because he wouldn't let go of this heel hook and
like Tokyo is trying to like hug it out and they're trying to explain to him,
no,
you were supposed to let go.
And it was almost like he didn't quite get what was going,
I took a lot.
If you watch that took a while for them to explain it to him,
like,
you know,
you can send to the frenzy of,
it may be,
I don't know.
I don't know dude.
You could also make the argument that he's playing dumb.
I don't know.
I don't know the guy.
I don't mean,
but if I,
if that was my student that was,
he was tearing apart like that,
I would,
I would say this guy's fucking playing dumb.
He knows he's not supposed to rip your leg apart like that.
That,
that ref though.
What's his name?
Uh,
with the Jake Shell's pipe.
You see him,
you're watching him.
It was a Steve Mazzagatti fight if I don't remember.
I don't think it was mom's got it.
Like you don't see him taking into his eyes like that.
You're a raft and you'd host of his eyes were all red and it was crazy.
Oh that was awful.
I'm never critical but that,
that,
that there's just no excuse for that.
That was awful.
He did a seminar cause he's top team and I was top team in long beach from
Carlson,
Gracie and everything.
And my coach calls me and he says,
um,
I wasn't in town at the time.
He goes,
oh it's all keeners doing a seminar.
It should come back for this leg lock seminar or whatever.
And I remember thinking I'd want to learn the leg locks.
I don't know if I get on the mat with that dude.
Like I want him to show me stuff.
But if he's like I'm a demonstrate come here,
I'd be like,
I don't know if I'm bringing with them old school Gracie bubba dummies.
Yeah.
He would bring gummy and go show me on that guy.
Cause it's different though when it,
when it's just a straight grappling match.
Yeah.
Come on.
You're not trying to,
no one's trying to break anybody's bones here,
but it's a little bit different.
And then the May,
when your opponent has no problem,
tried to put his fist through your stove or your skull fight.
He w he would love it if he kicked you right in the head and broke your fucking
orbital.
Yeah,
she would love it and no one would ever talk shit on him.
But at the crank,
a heal hook and you'd tear,
they're tending a little bit,
you know,
then you're the fucking bad guy.
But it's also,
he doesn't stop when you're,
when,
when the guy's tapping,
you know what I'm saying?
They stopped.
They have to respect the time you're trying to break my skull.
I'm trying to break your tongue or what's the difference?
But the guys,
but,
but once again,
the guys who hit the ground,
the refs to stop and they're still trying to hit her to that guy,
that guy.
It's the same thing.
You got to stop punching with the referee gets in your what period.
Yeah.
But what about,
what about in situations like Dan Henderson and bill and a
fighter's know when a guy's fucking done?
Yep.
He hit Bisbing so hard for sure.
Dan Henderson knew he was done,
but the rep was like 10 yards away.
So Dan innocent.
He was like,
damn,
I got a free shot.
Check this out.
Boom.
It makes highlight reels.
That's okay.
It's okay.
It all like
I put them in the same category.
Exactly.
If you don't get no respect that the stop of the fight,
it's bad.
Just a little tendon
as much as you get seven.
Does this make you feel uncomfortable about your own body when you watch these
guys?
Cause they basically weigh what you weigh or they wait in no way.
What you want to reason.
I'll never ultimately be happy.
That's,
that's cause you're not built like that.
That's exactly right.
And I would never wear clothes.
I would always be in shorts.
Like that would have like a hoodie opened up all the way.
Right.
Walked on the beach with no shirt.
Ain't be that guy 100% you'd have a book in his back pocket that was all dog
yeared but he really never read it.
That's true.
I that was,
that's what was my round.
Jack went to help you know what to help you.
You don't want to help you in these moments and you'll appreciate this.
Cause we were talking about Bobby Fischer last time.
That same documentary.
Yes.
Bobby Fischer against the world.
You'd have to watch.
But remember when the guy says,
imagine a whole of the things you did as a kid after school and before school
and imagine all of that is filled up with cest study and that's all you did.
So you can complain.
You're not that guy,
but you're sitting here drinking wine and cheese.
That dude's in the gym.
You are correct.
Like all the stuff I do that doesn't have anything to do with getting yoked.
I get to do all that stuff.
That's the,
I mean that's all.
And why aren't I as good at grappling six and Gracie,
think of all you did while Hixon Gracie was on a mat and just training.
You were doing other stuff.
That's what I like about [inaudible] is one of my all time favorite grappling
characters.
Not just cause he's the all time greatest legacy but also because he
incorporated yoga.
He was so outside the box.
He is doing what a lot of Jujitsu guys are doing now.
Incorporating Yoga,
MMA guys incorporate nutrition to every night when I want to choke together.
I think,
yeah,
the first time tough aren't going way back.
We wanted to do push ups.
Look at this,
jump around,
look at this,
looking at each other.
These guys are these guys.
Who's the last guy?
Meek fought.
Uh,
that's a good question.
That guy,
I think you pronounce it Mac.
I think it's a meal.
Yeah,
he's a,
he is hanging straight up viking.
100% and you've got a west African warrior over here.
Ooh,
from Nigeria.
You got.
What's going to be interesting is if mek can stuff that takedown.
Ken,
he stuff to take down.
Came out drunken monkey for a second.
It came out nice and low.
Now
got the neck.
Oh Shit.
Handful dark and full guard.
Oh.
Comoro.
Well,
that's not good is it guys?
Well now just the crush on his right side.
How much,
how much does he burned himself out here?
Does he go for it or does he let it go and this beast is on top of him dropping
elbows.
Not Okay here.
Well,
the harder to finish.
That's how his arm into [inaudible] and it's a lot hard to finish it right now.
I would say he's fine.
He doesn't have it by now.
Yeah.
It's trying to put all his weight on his right side.
Okay.
It all depends on his,
his left side.
I
don't know how good it squeezes.
Oh,
he's tightened down because he's got the wrong card.
This is a great position.
This is it.
Yes,
it's great.
You know how to finish it.
He's deep.
He's under that Chin,
man.
I don't look good.
That's not good.
Oh,
he's way lighter now.
Way Lighter.
Look at all that air.
See all that air.
Yeah.
And just keeps going.
It gets given up on it.
He's popping out right now and a meal's going to try to step up.
Oh,
he's trying to get that Comoros going to hold him down and now,
oh,
I don't like that.
Interesting.
Tomorrow taking him to the cage.
He's got a pass to get the hidden our homework from garden.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe with that fence there's something there.
You know what I mean?
It may be puts enough energy into it,
but it just happened the first time.
But he could just pass one leg and hold this position being get to half guard
and just keep this upper body.
Yeah,
you can do it.
Yeah.
It's a good question.
Um,
Jamie,
see if you could pull up.
Ooh.
Spawns wrestling pedigree.
I'm pretty sure he's NCAA.
All American.
Yikes.
And more than that,
I think maybe two years,
I'd have to remember,
go over my notes.
Look at daddy wants to back stepping back up or stepping up though Nigeria had
an Olympian and Daniel Lee,
golly,
who went to Canon and then one gold medal in 2000 and he's trying to take the
back.
As far as I know,
it was not a lot of great wrestling out of their three year old American d two.
Yeah,
three year.
All American division too.
All right,
cool.
And what uh,
what university?
University of Nebraska at Kearney.
Same as Ellenberger.
That's a real number one for the Camorra.
I'll look at this.
Look at this.
Oh boy.
Interesting.
Interesting,
interesting.
Interesting.
Ooh,
he's got it in low.
He's got a nice and low,
I don't really turn his hips though and the fence is getting in the way a little
bit.
Okay.
He's defended it.
Nice.
Still called controlling that risk though.
It doesn't want to let it go.
Interesting.
Can't get that arm over going basket and go.
But yeah,
it's a lot of muscle feels.
It goes later.
Well,
it's a lot of,
it's a lot of whole lot of tension on the muscles,
but we've been wrestling for a long time.
He used to it.
We're talking about Camaro and Nigerian wrestlers.
I mean,
where is,
uh,
is a meal from Iceland?
What's,
what's Viking Norway?
What does the ice
was Norway.
The flag was normal.
Denmark.
Norway,
I think Sweden.
Where,
where is he from though?
Is He,
he's from,
uh,
find out.
Jamie said,
look at this.
This is a battle baby.
This is a battle.
You got a couple of Camaros.
Oh.
Stablish established that dominate from Norway,
Norway,
Norway.
Bunch of fucking tough people in Norway.
He's guys nails painted.
I liked those toenails I painted.
I appreciate it very much.
Frank Trigg,
they're painted chocolate down.
Worships the devil.
Oh,
sure.
He's probably the druid and it's ruined what?
It's a male,
which I thought that was a warlock.
They're experts at Po.
Do you imagine this?
I love the how,
the what is like,
I don't know what to drew it is.
It's more that you're calling him a druid.
Druids
leaves somebody who was into magic and Amil Mech back up.
Oh hold on.
Meal Mex standing up.
But here's the thing,
he can't keep Guzman off them.
The question is whether or not loose mark can continue like this pace and keep
doing this close.
She's be breathing pretty,
but how's,
how's mech going to feel once he gets free?
Cause you're holding your weight and the other guys was burnt out here.
Who's going to be more burnt out?
I mean we're,
we're likely looking at the end of the first round where Comoro controls him and
does,
you know most of the control but really didn't get much off.
Oh that's an interesting,
they had the dog don't push.
Okay,
well keep them square.
Wanna keep getting in front of you.
Who's a meal met training with?
I was just going to ask that.
I like to see his Joji.
It's with Thor
in Valhalla.
Oh Nice.
Right.
I watched star wars today.
How was it?
I'm senior.
It was like a Disney star wars movie.
It's like the,
everything's super diversified.
The characters are all black and Asian women and women that are generals.
The women are running things.
It's like,
yeah,
that's a loss.
Yeah,
a game of Thrones.
It.
No,
no,
no.
Ooh.
Little after the bell action there.
It was.
Okay.
I was like,
get off as a fun movie.
It was fun,
but it was just like,
it's like Disney got dignified.
It's like they just boiled all the bacteria off
Marxist Markson file.
It's just,
it's just,
you know,
it's,
I don't,
I like a strong female character,
but I don't want to think that this is like a calculated move for you to create
a strong female character is the cat because you want,
but I don't want this to notice that.
I know.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Somebody told me that about the black mirror somebody could play.
They said,
oh,
all the fucking heroes and this season's black mirror.
All women.
Like if you watch the black mirror and that's what you're concentrating on
Europe asshole does.
That fucking shows amazing.
It's astonishing.
Nobody gives a fuck.
It's because women,
the lead or men who lead,
it's just a phenomenal show.
I want to turn it off halfway through.
I haven't seen this with me anymore.
I haven't seen the season dimes,
this seasons,
the greatest ever.
It's amazing.
Battle dogs.
Crazy.
Right?
Here we go.
Why don't you,
I don't be getting out.
Let's see if Matt,
who he's going right to the head kicks,
but here's the thing.
Does Ou smog get tired?
Does he get tired after all that grapple?
Fuck doesn't look tired.
It doesn't look tired.
Is Mech tired?
The OE front kick to the body Mack?
I liked the fact that he's still throwing kicks.
Even though he got taken down at dominated on the ground.
He's tried to set something.
Oh,
and another hard kick to the arms.
Not Fun.
Not Fun to take those.
If you're holding tie pads,
don't you have to be careful about catching the top of your foot on those
elbows.
Ooh,
when I was not thinking about that.
Yeah,
that can't stop.
Once again,
if you're thinking about it,
he's thinking about slamming that Shin into those fucking forearms and making
them useless.
Ooh,
those are,
oh,
we heard them.
He heard them with that.
Spin it back test.
Damn.
He heard her elbow.
That was at herring.
Nice.
Spinning back fist.
Very.
Unless they're ow.
Ow.
Oh,
oh.
Ow.
Ducked under that hand.
Get out of their son.
Go.
Here we go.
All right.
Somebody's gonna.
Oh,
it's reachable now.
I'm a little bit,
oh,
there.
He gets there.
He gets it.
Let it go,
son.
Get out of there.
Get it out of their Mac.
Interesting though.
Ooh.
Someone does not want no part of that.
Fucking stand on.
I don't think so.
Not enjoying it.
Nope.
It doesn't want to be throwing bones with a viking.
Yeah.
That's a long history of fucking people up.
Where did he,
Nebraska.
Kearney,
wizard.
It's got that wizard.
Ooh.
Oh,
it was mine.
Oh Mom.
I'm going over the head almost at the back.
Should have kept that wizard right.
Should have kept it
damn.
Interesting.
How to score this.
Right,
because loose bomb,
when he gets it to the ground,
he's been not able to do anything.
Yeah.
And trolls him,
but he's not getting anything off and it's Mecca went for the submissions in the
first round.
He's the one we tried to finish by then.
Clearly Uzman does not want to stand with them.
He's trying to,
trying to bring this into hands around.
Well,
stand up without giving up your back.
Yeah,
he doesn't want it.
He doesn't want me to stand up too high and get hooks in.
Okay.
So it's,
it's about guarding your hips and standing up the same time.
That's also why you see he's got his right hip press.
Nice and square.
Yeah.
He's trying to keep that left hook or the right hook rather from getting in.
And use it back up again.
Interesting.
Trying to separate those arms.
A lot of battle in here.
A lot of fucking physical war.
This is going to be in a lot of ways like who's going to be a the fitter
fighter.
Yeah,
it is.
But a bad man keeps standing up and again going for that tomorrow.
Come on,
got to wash it.
And that's the commitment to the hips.
He's going to it going to work,
but it's too close to that.
Yeah.
Too close to the fence and it doesn't really have anything going on with his
legs.
He likes it though.
He's holding it.
That's his shit.
He's a muscle dude.
That's a real muscle move.
Yeah.
It's funny,
you know,
Marcello Garcia doesn't use cameras
to do anything with that.
Kamora if he gets that or I find that amazing.
But he does take,
it does take a lot of commitment with the hubs to get them,
get it.
C'Mon generally speak to me or you blacked out.
Yeah.
You fought too,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're going to say Kamora is,
I think with Marcello means by that.
And um,
is that,
uh,
Camorra's definitely work.
Yeah,
they certainly do.
There's no,
there's an elaborate systems around more
as cores a fucking huge,
oh yeah.
But I see what he says.
Cause when you're,
if you're going to go with someone who has 2030 pounds on,
you Kamora knock an war from the bottom.
That's a guy who was saying with all the options I have,
I would just say,
I mean,
he's got a lot of other options not sitting there thinking just about the
Kimora.
It's a lot of options.
Every time he attacks he goes from risks a lot,
so I think it's just the harder way to go with all the options he has.
He said that makes sense though.
He says he wants to spend time working on submissions and only time.
I like all this time that work on big guys jokes,
jokes.
He wouldn't open division at North Cobb,
Adobe all the time.
He just wants to get good at stuff that works on bigger guys.
If it doesn't work on bigger guys,
he doesn't want to spend time and he had leg lock game too.
He's fantastic.
Like Rodriguez.
Yeah,
I remember that after he slammed him.
that was 10 was dark dirty.
If you wanted to be a juggler,
he did to him.
He got garden anymore because I'm bigger.
I'm stronger.
Lock them down,
get rid of his mobility and go for the camera.
I remember that quick.
That was the last,
yeah.
Okay.
Mac on the bottom here,
man.
Starting to get cut up to,
well,
he got some good elbows off of from the bottom and then Comoros started smashing
on him.
He was angry when you're on top of somebody for this long though,
is that scored at yeah,
sure.
Control.
You're in the dominant position and also your strikes count for more.
So when it comes to significant strikes,
your stretching more significant basically.
Yeah.
And clearly wants to keep the fight to ground.
Clearly mech wants to get up and he can't.
So it shows dominance,
a position.
It shows the ability to execute your data in and around.
Told Best.
Yeah.
I've been looking forward to somebody challenging loose mine,
but so you see some vulnerabilities in the standup?
Yeah.
See you a little bit of that.
You know,
and Mac being a strong dangerous guy,
but you also see moose months strengths,
his ability to keep fights going down now.
What kind of cheeses do you get?
Raw Cheese.
Do you one of those fellows is a beautiful,
that is good cheeses.
Manchego cheese.
Is it be stanchions this Rochez I don't know.
You don't know?
That's it.
It's a beautiful,
do you get it at whole foods that's and check I've ever had.
Thank you my man.
Ooh,
that's really good to see what it is.
I don't play around when it comes to champ.
You do not there.
I'll play around in Carol.
Mm.
Awesome.
Good God damn choose you ever have a good vegan cheese?
No.
Do they exist?
Yeah,
they're cashew cheese.
You can kiss my ass with that stuff.
Really?
It's not cheesy.
Stop reinventing the wheel.
What is it?
That was me crazy.
They made out of cashews and stuff.
But is it a like a,
a valid substitution?
Dramatic.
Actually,
I'm kidding,
but you aren't.
I don't know.
You're a serious,
my wife eats it.
Here we go.
Round three don.
Don,
Tom.
Do you say get the fuck out of my face with that shit when you see you're eating
it.
So
I'm just curious.
Take that communist stuff out of my fucking house.
Interesting.
Both guys look pretty good in this third round.
Eddie,
you're a Vegan now I my mouth.
I'm like,
oh no.
Well I mean you look good either way.
That's all I know.
And he looks,
Eddie doesn't age well.
He especially now off the booze.
He does not meet your face.
Your face is 85 years old.
How old are you?
47 damn,
man.
You look young.
You really do.
Yeah.
Oh,
not shot toes caught it kind.
No,
not that bad,
but like that.
Ooh.
All right.
Well it just doing that weird drop thing that never works.
You know what's funny is a lot of people like complain online,
you know,
whatever.
You know fans are like,
oh,
that wasn't a bad shot.
A lot of times the ones that don't look bad slammed the cup right into your nuts
and they're the worst.
The grading shots lessons,
the worst ones,
they shift the cup.
Nice.
That kind of square.
One more problem.
Yeah,
it's got to get those goddamn compression cups like diamond MMA,
they have that compression short with a cup that keeps everything locked in and
tight.
That's what you want.
Oh wait,
I boys scoring with,
I hit him with a hard shot to the body and a good right hand behind it.
It's interesting because if you look at like who did damage clearly,
Ooh,
smog got off some of the damage in that first round,
but you can't discount all this.
You cannot,
don't,
don't go back to the ground.
I want to come on and let me see this slug fest.
Hammer hammering with those elbows.
Travis Browne is going down.
Son Jesus probably,
but not going to be able to get up.
Damn it.
Here we go again.
He's just working for that head and arm choke again.
But again he's stuck in full guard.
Seems rudimentary.
Yes and he hasn't been there.
Yeah,
I was getting no path.
It seems like he's just kind of trying to hold that spot with that left arm
trapped,
but he doesn't really have a,
a real option.
Mix An animal though.
He is an animal but animal,
but he's fucked here.
Oh Nice.
Nice.
Back to it.
Oh,
can spot them right back on them.
That's it.
That's as much happy place.
Boy,
he'll,
he'll just that pressure.
She didn't want anyone that didn't want none of that.
Do want to be staring at your old school switch.
The old school rustling switch ma'am.
Good luck.
Yeah,
for sure.
I don't get that at all.
You got to get that like right away.
It was someone's just got such a better work once a fiberglass ones.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Ouch.
That's got to hurt.
So you see,
you see how strong it was,
smiles wrestling is but you also see vulnerability.
Yeah definitely see vulnerability in standup.
I don't think it's going to be as hard for him to get fights now tell you that
he'll be able to get a few guys that will step in and he's fighting a strong guy
but he's been fighting a tricky,
you know a guy that's going to throw weird stuff at him cause he's reached a few
times so those take downs and the guy hasn't had me cats and had the speed to
really make him pay for it.
Somebody else
will.
Him versus Mike Perry would be very interesting.
Him versus my Darren till.
It'd be interesting.
That would be horrific.
In other words,
it hurt.
Manage for the standup for till.
Big,
big advantage.
Darren till is a wizard.
He's going to be,
I think if,
I don't know what his wrestling's like against a guy like Tyron or something,
but I don't know how he stops that.
But um,
if he does have great takedown defense,
I think he's gonna.
He's gonna,
he's gonna walk through that division,
not walk through.
Well,
you saw it almost immediately in the cowboy fight.
He was on so many levels higher than cowboy when it came to stand up distance
control and then consequences for his actions.
I hit so fucking hard.
That's what I'm looking at.
Two Oh one.
He's a huge guy.
He's able to get down to one 70.
Oh my.
He's 24 years old and she's super technical too.
It's not,
it's not just big.
He's big and real technical.
And he stepped into a big fight,
late notice and acted like this is my,
this is my moment.
A lot of guys mentally fold.
And he did not very confident.
There's no folded in that guy.
You know,
Vinny shoreman.
Vinnie does,
um,
Moitai commentary for a bunch of organizations and he's also a,
a fight hypnotists.
Really interesting guy.
And uh,
you know,
he knows a lot about the tie world and Thai fighting and he's always talking to
me about dudes.
And when he found out that till was fighting cowboy,
he was very excited.
He called me up or sent me text messages about and we went back and forth quite
a bit.
He was like,
this guy is something special,
he's something special.
So it really prompted me to go watch some tils fights and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And he's monsters,
you know,
in cowboy was like,
I ain't watch tape on him or her.
He lacks a strike.
Good.
I love striking.
I was like,
this fight is going to be fucking crazy.
How tall is till he's tall.
He's like six [inaudible] two,
I think.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a big fucking guy.
He goes,
I'm,
I'm a light heavyweight.
Kick him away.
Still up,
standing up now.
Oh
so dominant performance by Guzman in the fact that he got in the second and the
third round to do really basically what he wanted.
Took some punishment on the feet,
but here we go.
Oh,
the full amount now.
And he stepped right back into half guard.
Yup.
Yeah.
You see the weaknesses?
You see where he needs some improvement?
Well,
the big one to me is the standup.
His staff,
he's,
he looks like he's thinking,
you know what I'm saying?
Like when things are going down,
he's thinking and it's instinct is to reach,
just go.
Okay.
Reaching their guys at the other really make you pay for that.
Yeah.
I want to see him versus a guy who can really fucking bang.
That's why I think that,
uh,
he's bummed out.
Amil Max bummed out.
MMM.
But,
uh,
I feel like I'm seeing,
oops Mont against a guy who might be able to stuff those takedowns and maybe
have a little bit faster hands and Mac Meccas Tophen is standup as good,
but this is a real dude that doesn't,
doesn't have like any one overwhelming feature to his game.
Whereas a guy like Mike Perry can blow your fucking brains through the back of
your head.
You know?
I mean that like I hit so goddamn hard.
He's so ferocious.
I'd like to see him,
but I don't think you'd be,
it's gotta be able to stop that take down.
This guy's got some fucking wicked wrestling.
Interesting though.
He learned a lot tonight.
Tell you that that's a fight like that is good for a guy like him and we got to
see him in vulnerable positions.
Did not like the stand up.
Wow.
Interesting.
And he was in trouble a couple of guns a couple of times and he's a guy who's
not super duper slick on the ground and he was still like,
oh,
Kimora teen.
So yeah,
especially the good team,
like right away.
I mean,
what if he had gotten locked up like that with a guy who was like a wicked
finisher?
Yeah.
Christian Bale is the best actor in Hollywood is as long as Daniel stays making
shoes is my favorite.
But I got this from the,
they'll right there with him.
He's right there where the love,
I love Daniel Day Lewis,
but Christian Bale,
he ne here's the,
here's the trivia question.
What was the one movie he was in when he was younger?
Uh,
while he was in two movies.
He's been acting since he was six and part of the sun.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
So don't even throw your star,
Bro.
You hear me talk it out across the site.
There's one more.
Henry the fifth with Canada.
Toronto.
He has a little bit,
but,
but I love that you got that.
I love you.
I'm already impressed with your degree in history.
Dog had said,
why don't
you go to school,
university,
Ucla.
All right,
you're off a degree in history.
I was already a fan when I listened to you.
I'm broken.
I went,
this fucking guy is,
but you didn't know.
Dude.
Dude love you for that history trivia.
Jimmy's like,
thank you sir.
God,
I love that dude.
I'm so happy that you're with the UFC know and happy to be.
He's happy to be here.
We tried to get you for years.
For years.
Yeah,
man.
He's as knowledgeable,
but there's some guys doing commentary right now.
We're just saying there's a guy who was doing on this fight that we don't know
who he is.
Who is this guy?
What is his name is Paul Felder's.
Paul felter.
But again,
a major Paul felter get back.
Yes.
He was great guy.
I,
um,
when I saw,
I watched him fight a lot,
including life and I,
he just looks like such an animal.
So I,
and when I met him,
I expected this kind of real kind of antisocial or our rough guy and he's the
exact opposite theater major.
Very intelligent.
Just a,
just a good soap or dude,
you know,
Super Nice Guy,
great guy.
And just as tough as it gets,
come on.
What was mom clearly nanos decision.
I'm very impressed with both those guys.
Yeah.
Fuck
yeah.
Interesting fight though.
I'm glad that fight happened.
Got to see it and you're right.
Ooh,
someone's going to get more people in.
Oh yeah.
I can meet that guy,
which can be good for you.
Yes,
can we do,
you don't want people to run from it.
He's going to get guys that are going to be willing to fight him now because
he's got a strong presence in the top 10 I mean he's number 10 now.
Winning this fight probably keeps them in that area because Mac is probably not
ranked because that hook is,
I haven't left.
Where is he?
Am I looking at it and to the left of anyone?
They just shut them up perhaps.
I Dunno.
It was mine.
I know it's right there.
You guys are saying people are going to want to find him now.
Yeah,
I think so.
More people before.
Yeah,
look,
he's no,
he's no picnic
African could be.
No.
He could be the loud guy.
No doubt about it.
No,
I,
well there was some vulnerabilities in there.
It could be all.
It can be.
I think he's very good.
Don't get me wrong,
but I think that a meals without real fast hands showed some real
vulnerabilities.
Yeah.
Like you know,
if he was,
here's a PR like okay,
let's put it this way.
If Calvin gasoline could really make 170 to be healthy,
like if he,
if he got it,
Mike Dolce on speed dial and said,
Mike,
let's work this out.
Let's just make this work out.
Maybe come on,
I don't know,
70 unit.
We both though seventies where it's at.
And if they actually did figure out a way to get a good meal plan,
drop them down the way.
Like Michael Johnson looked,
you know,
Calvin's got way better hands.
I mean wait and Kelvins tough to take down.
He's a real good wrestler.
He never gets fucking tired.
His endurance is phenomenal and he packed hard to get underneath and tasted
nasty southpaw and that fucking right jab,
straight left behind.
It is surprising.
It's got snapped to it when he cracked Bisbing with that shit.
Yeah.
And when it was like,
and you see Bisping's head snapped back,
you were like,
there's some pop to that dude's punches.
He stopped v toward that way.
Same Way.
He's a motherfucker that Kelvin Gaslamp.
You see,
I would love to see that.
I mean,
obviously Kelvin's campaigning at one 85 now and maybe he's going to stay there
now.
He wants to go back down one seven.
I would love to see that fight.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what I want to say.
I want to see Calvin versus Huseman.
I think that's a real good fight because I don't think Calvin's ranked at one 70
right,
because he's been fighting at 85 right.
Right now he's not.
Right.
So he goes down to 70 and [inaudible] top 10 immediately he's ranked,
you know,
if he can beat who spawn.
And it's a big f because it was mom's a hell of a fucking wrestler.
And one day he five hosts a monsters.
Monsters,
monsters.
Dude.
Fucking soap bombed out or they canceled this fight that Whitaker Whitaker.
Yeah.
What happened?
Got Injured Hero Romero Yoel Romero was going to fight for the interim title
against Luke Rockhold,
which is a lovely,
that's lovely.
But not a lot of time.
That's February,
right?
No.
When is that?
Uh,
no,
it's February when,
what I'm saying,
but he was already on the car.
He was supposed to fight well with Berendsen.
Oh,
okay.
So he was,
he was our least in camp for that date,
which is he has,
what's wrong with Whitaker?
What injury did they announce it?
I don't think they announced it.
I don't remember.
Yes,
I would bet it's his knee.
His knee got fucked up in that fight with EOL Yo side kicked his knee and hyper
extended it and he came back and he said my knees fucked in between rounds and
still stuff to take downs and still beat him standing.
He's as tough as he,
he's got,
he's Mallory,
right?
It's Kinda,
yeah,
but he's got extra,
he's got a lot of terror.
There's a lot of tears going on in that knee,
so he's going to have to figure out what the fuck to do about all that.
It needs.
New head are not made for sport,
for Combat Sport,
that's for sure.
Not at all.
Yeah man.
It's a real bummer.
When guys started having knee injuries,
repeated knee injuries,
like until they get that ironed out and settled in,
it's like,
it's always suspect that shit's always given out and then you're training
changes.
So then your ability inside the octagon changes.
So many things change.
And me Ma,
Eddie Bravo is over here.
Hope and dudes get their legs were up to party.
He was like,
fuck,
he's all quiet and really,
no,
I just want you to talk.
He'll be quiet.
But um,
how have your baskets was the guy who was right about to break through and that
happened.
Well,
hobbies needs,
we're fucked.
God.
I know,
I know.
His knees are real brutal crane fight.
He couldn't stand up.
Can you the cage remember that?
Well,
he had a blown ACL.
I commented thought did you,
I remember that.
That was my last one.
I remember her sitting down.
He blew it.
You were drunk.
Took shots.
And it was my last show.
Oh Man.
We went off.
Me and Eric Apple did it.
Eric,
I got to see that apple.
Damn,
it's Alberto crank.
Great Jujitsu Guy.
And however your basket is great.
You just guiding them for the kingdom.
The cage title.
Yeah.
Well,
and hobby was like about to break that.
I was supposed to be like,
it just stopped.
Sorry,
from the injury.
If he just let go and just say,
look,
I'm injured,
I got to stop this fight.
His career would have taken a completely different path and it's his mental
toughness,
his ability to endure and fight with that ACL and it kept blowing out during the
fight.
It just kept giving out.
So he must've chewed up the whole inside of his fucking leg,
his meniscus and all that shit,
but still went on to be like a really good fighter in MMA and a really good
fucking sub Matt submission grappling,
find Ebi a bunch of times with those knees.
Didn't he run into some health issues recently?
Cancer,
I believe he beats you got on the Gerson method.
Who is,
what's the Gerson method?
A lot of juicing like coffee enemas.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Choosing a lot of animal,
the animals.
Something like,
I don't know,
something like that.
What kind of cancer was it?
Worked?
It worked in the cancer.
He had a um,
colon,
colon cancer.
Okay.
So that makes sense with the enemas.
So joke.
Fuck man.
So he beat it.
That's beautiful.
God,
it's at 50.
You should all have like I had to get my fucking call them the finger up your
butt hole.
I got to clean but huh?
I was willing to stick a tube up there at the camp.
Did you like wrap your legs around your arms?
Like this year there was a private,
I'm not too proud to come there.
That's a private,
that's a private question.
Did you like get up?
He smelled like how long?
He's right now showing you my doctor smelling Cologne and he was a really nice
guy and he didn't wear gloves.
Yeah,
you're showing us how it's done Joe.
Like check this out.
That's how you do it bro.
As breast milk.
Pineapple.
Yeah,
that's all I'm gonna say.
I was talking to a guy the other day that had mint breath over shit breath.
It was so confused at Terrell told him that his breath smelled like shit.
And so he was eating mince,
but it wasn't good enough.
The meds.
So it was like I was,
it was,
you know what it was like,
man.
It was like,
like it was confusing.
It was like just two signals that were clashing with each other.
What's awful for folks listening at home that aren't broadcasters,
I'm not naming names,
we're not going to name any names to broadcasts with somebody who's
breastfeeding because they turned to you and you have to stay close to them to
stay in the two shot a problem.
You can't go,
you can't react to it all.
It's a problem.
And it is.
I brushed my teeth like religiously when I'm doing camera stuff because I'm in
someone's face talking to them and I've been on the receiving end of that and
been like this.
And you can't make show face.
You can't do it.
Yeah.
After shows when you take pictures.
Ooh,
that's got to be girls and guys.
So Nice.
You're just like,
God damn it.
I don't know what's going on.
They say when people don't eat a lot,
like if you,
uh,
yeah.
Is that real?
Like if you a fancy things.
I know with a chronic halitosis,
apparently it's the sulfates on your tongue.
Whoa.
There's a,
there's a so,
so typically I guess the,
so,
so the chemicals,
I guess the sulfur that everybody has different compounds in their mouth and for
whatever reason,
I don't know.
But you,
they're,
they're essentially what you're smelling is sulfur is,
is a derivative of software or some kind of assault and it's because there's a
chemical problem in your mouth and they can actually address it with things.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And also I was like,
tell him to tell us,
this can also be from bad from liver disease.
So if you have a liver disease,
you um,
yeah.
Liver disease,
make sure they check his diabetes,
heart disease,
stuff like about the breath.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
That's one of the ways they check.
Whoa.
And then of course it can be,
uh,
an abscess behind your tooth and all that.
Yeah,
that's a big one,
man.
That's what I mean.
Everyone sees and diabetes,
diabetics,
dude,
I had a cracked filling and they took the filling out.
Oh.
And the fucking smell that came out of my mouth,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Cause the,
the filling had cracked and there was an infection and I had a wound up getting
a root canal.
And so as I'm getting this list thing like opened up,
they break through this pocket.
We're all this puss and rot is,
yeah.
Oh Dude,
it was so nasty.
Sounds awful.
Like you could hear it like pop through and then just this fucking shit breath.
They caught my thighs.
My father is fine.
He was sleeping,
his wife said you have to go to dentist.
So why does your breath is so out of control and they've been married for 25
years.
So because Jesus,
all right,
so,
so check this out.
This is so apparently he had an abscess,
a sack of bacteria in the back of his mouth.
Well when they,
when they,
I guess took the tooth out of the filling out and they popped by accident,
the sac,
the nurse through,
well
fucking dentist walked into the room at that moment
and through the [inaudible] a double vomit fest.
Ooh.
She didn't be better if she just puked when Buddha statue
and when he had his mask on,
he went got just barely diamond
like that.
Oh,
Ms. Dot.
that's so cool.
I never had the balls to tell someone their breaths.
If you work with them,
you have to tell friends.
Where would want them to tell me like your breath stinks.
I'm going to tell you test and I would want you to tell me.
It's one cool thing about black people.
They'll tell you
no problem with that.
Have no block or some shit.
Fucking pussy.
I once got head from a girl.
She was,
she would come over and give me a massage.
She wasn't very good looking,
but she was down to give them a song.
By the time you're done with the massage,
she knows she's going to get to,
she wanted to give me oral pleasure long time ago,
but she used her teeth.
Oh boy.
I didn't have the fucking courage to tell her that.
I'm like,
you're shouting.
I was enjoying it.
Oh,
she's looking at me.
[inaudible] every time she came over right.
Here we go.
[inaudible]
a girl's pussy can reek and I'm not going to tell him.
That's a tough
one.
I'm not telling me,
Oh shit,
I gotta be a gentleman,
but okay.
But if you're a girl and you have a problem,
you have a yeast infection and if someone doesn't let you know,
you're not going to get it treated.
There's a problem.
Like it's true.
It's delicate.
It's a delicate,
you're not always going to get a rational reaction.
Thank you.
Medically I feel much better.
That's not going to be
mad at you.
Isn't that weird?
They'll get mad at you if their pussy stank.
Well,
there was a girl that,
I was in New York.
I was a young man and she was very sexy and uh,
I feel like the incredible hulk music should be playing right now.
She met me with a hat on.
I remember this weird thing.
She met with a hat on.
I picked her up and she goes,
good.
Thank God.
I thought you were going to be bald.
I was like,
it was like 20 thanks.
Thanks.
Whatever.
To ballgames.
And she and I,
we got to business and then she began to give me oral pleasure after she was,
I had gotten her kind of naked and she had a Harry,
but she had a hairy back.
Like you know,
some people can be super dark hair and it was,
first was that it was fine for a girl it was girl for,
but it's still a problem bro,
because they,
the hair fanned out.
It started with the back and it was on the old rumper still skins and that was
very hard for me to keep it.
I couldn't,
I had to avert my eyes.
The only black girl know what was the instinct to laugh when she hears what the
instinct was.
He had a big Dick,
but
I'm kidding.
But I'm,
no,
it wasn't.
I just kind of,
there's no way I was going to,
what do I say?
No To area on your back and your rump.
I mean,
you know,
I,
I just,
I just dealt with it.
I didn't pull out a medical book on one girl though.
I liked her a lot side.
How does she ended up being my girlfriend,
I showed her that she had a B vitamin deficiency.
Wow.
And that's why it was a really,
it was problems down there.
Oh Wow.
She got all into vitamins.
She was vitamin freak from that point on.
And you know what,
she me,
I went on a date with a girl that's the worst threat in the world.
And I had,
and she was from,
I knew her in college and I said to her friend,
I said,
shit,
what happened with her uncle?
You want me to be honest?
So I said her breath was so bad I could smell it when we're standing at the
elevator.
And she screamed.
She went,
Oh my God,
we've always felt that way.
And they were friends with her and I said,
none of you told her her life is,
she'll never find somebody if you don't tell her.
I couldn't tell her.
You guys will tell you quick like a group of guys and I be like,
Joe,
you got to take care of this now.
But I couldn't say it to the girl cause I just felt,
you know I would thank you.
I think it's important you page fans that loves that jump in switch.
Kick jumping roundhouse kick to the fighting.
By the way,
his word and Paige vanzant and who is Clark?
What is her first name?
Ooh,
nice leg kick.
Jessica Clark.
Is that it?
You just make that up?
No
Way.
He said it was like it was a 10 stick.
10th of a joke to it.
Ooh.
Wow.
Paige vanzant is throwing along for wild a leaping in shit.
Casey Halston,
head instructor,
10 Planet Las Vegas is working with her with Clark page.
Click hard in the funny how I feel bad about telling that story about the girl
with the hair on her back and I didn't know it was,
it was 25 years ago.
I mean,
you know,
no hates Trish.
She's not listening to this.
Gonna say jerk page.
Loves that jumping roundhouse.
Kick pages.
Busy here man.
Yeah,
but she's a,
she got tagged like several click there.
This girl Clark has some clean striking good counters.
Yeah.
Now.
See that was a problem when we're talking about the trip,
the Cyborg Holly Holm fight,
she would get in quick and the that counter every time.
Paige is in trouble on her back side control.
No,
I'm good.
What do you want to do here?
Stand up right away.
Or what if you're filling the bottom car?
Either get Gar to get up.
What was your knew generally,
what do you want to do here?
When we want to do here?
Who want to drive your fist in her face?
Who would kick her ass
edge?
Bravo.
I needed you brought there.
Ooh.
Standing arms triangle.
Oh,
oh,
oh page.
Full guard right there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Oh,
come on.
What's her name?
Clark Clark.
She has an arm triangle,
but it's hard to understand.
Much more serious as long as she needs is in trouble.
Three minutes to go.
She's in trouble and she doesn't have the best guard now you want to be on the
phone or don't you?
Oh yeah,
she wanted to be on the phone goes off.
She's off.
She's off the phone now and she's still,
she's still in trouble,
but not nearly as bad.
Plenty of space because her elbow to elbow from going across your neck.
If you're like,
extend your arm here,
you want to be here,
here's not as good.
You want to be on the phone.
But even that,
if someone's real strong,
it's not going to sit here.
She wants her right arm to under hook her neck or ha ha,
that didn't happen.
Brian.
Dan,
when he got choked out by a chill,
he was on the phone there and you can still,
it can still,
but here's the thing,
she's got to get out of this half guard and she wants to be on the same side as
the choke.
He had his leg in the escape and Dante has put them out.
It could especially who did you to do the impaler?
Do you know?
Uh,
Eddie,
you still use that?
That a knee to the chest wall separating that tailors the legit like that need
that,
um,
that escape where you're holding onto your own name.
Yeah,
it's not good enough.
But the guy knows that and Paler move and he gets that knee to your chest and
puts that crashed down.
I like that all day.
I think the time you spend defending that you're getting your ribs crushed,
it's so much pressure on you.
And if you make the decision to try to defend that and push that away,
you're going to give up more of the Cho.
And how do you get Tony Ferguson like prepared?
I mean it's kind of a weird question,
but with that kind of wrestling and that with the same kind of pressure,
how do you deal with that kind of
sure with,
cause I know we've been working on that since day one,
right?
You mean like getting prepared for Habib?
How did you get a pair for a dude who really necessarily fighting Khabib yet?
We don't,
there's no schedule,
but that's my prediction.
You gotta at least be that they get a map.
I think that's going to happen.
So we've prepared for that.
You know,
when we were working on um,
the Rafael does Anjos fight,
we were still thinking wrestling and you know,
Khabib is in the mix.
We have to be working on counter back.
Hey,
it's not going to be,
it's not going to be easy.
Well it paid off big and the Kevin Leafy right out triangle,
same camp.
Kevin Lee's wrestler.
Good passer loves to take the back.
Has a good rear naked choke.
Yeah,
same thing.
Yeah.
So Paige is in a lot of trouble here.
She's just defending and fighting for her life here off the bottom.
And the Clark has not really advanced any further than this one position where
she keeps trying to get this head and arm choke.
Just can't quite get it.
Would you Eddie,
would you like to see her like in a situation like this which keeps going to it
over and over and go,
would you like to see or just try to get out of that half guard first?
Exactly,
yeah.
Keep the position,
you know,
keep that head on the ground,
keep her arm trap,
but you got to pass the guard.
She's slant at Nice Elbow.
Got To get to the chopping block.
Okay.
She's slicing through now now because,
because Paige went after it.
Okay.
That right level left legs and play.
Oh,
back to Africa.
Yeah.
But almost out.
Oh No,
she's just gonna try smash now.
Ooh,
whoa.
That's it.
It's just saying whether you're,
whether you're,
whether you're trying to pass it or whether you're trying to use it.
There are,
there are submissions from half card and our submissions where you're passing up
or they're just hard to pull off.
It's always easier to get around dark.
Do you remember,
he goes easy to get around guard first.
Eddie,
do you remember,
was he getting Machado's version of the twister?
He had a different
version of the tourists.
He asked me to show it to him one day and I was like,
I was a purple belt and I couldn't believe a black belt allege.
And like Kagan Machado wanted,
he called me over and wanted to basically a private on the twister.
Yeah.
And um,
he remembered it wrong and came up with a whole different version.
So he called it the Higgins twister.
And only like three people can do it.
And it's amazing.
Now.
It's amazing,
man.
Um,
Ryan,
Greg is one of his black belt.
He remember,
I remember Ron.
He's the best at it.
That's so crazy to,
I wouldn't know how to show it.
I wouldn't know how to do it right now.
Oh,
interesting.
It's weird.
Very strange.
What would you say that only a few people can do it?
Like what's the separating thing?
Like what,
what keeps them from being able to do it?
It's just so unorthodox and so crazy.
It's like a,
some kind of pro wrestling move.
The jet,
it's almost like from half card,
right?
Like on top and half car.
I don't even remember it.
Just twist the body in a weird way.
It's kind of Nice.
Yeah.
So in a regular twister,
you would be underneath with your half guard,
locked around the left leg and you'd be pulling on the head with your hands
clasped together.
But his was from the top position,
right?
Is that Hagen twist it.
Hagen trust her.
Oh,
here we go.
It doesn't say that.
It says a half guard back.
Take to twister.
Oh,
this is different.
That won't,
that won't be it.
This is,
it's got to say,
Hey,
uh,
R I g a n Higgins twister.
Higgin Machado.
Twister.
He had his own way.
He might not have ever put it on youtube.
Probably highly likely did.
Might be up there.
Someone might know it came from that search.
That's why it was
amazing.
It's endless.
It's really is man.
Oh look,
it's a beautiful page.
Gets to take down page.
Just have,
ah,
I should have stuck with it.
I'm joking.
You could still go back to it,
man.
I might.
I like,
I like boxing so much.
Anthony Jordan game.
Then when I started,
uh,
recently.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
What Scott Ross,
he would literally fall is where Scott at these days,
he's teaching at HQ and the daytime.
Daytime and nighttime has a school in Culver City.
Right.
And is applied to this store called the city.
Yeah.
Right.
On that point you could go there.
Look,
you're in Venice.
You're,
you're near a lot of places.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that could teach you down there easily and well,
your boy Hernando is still down there.
Yeah.
And not so magnet.
Where's he at?
Yeah,
I got to figure it out.
He's still in the same spot.
Yeah.
I like boxing so much though.
It's so hard.
It's so fucking hard.
You mean physically look just tarring and had a fucking spar learning how to
like slip a jack to Mr on kicks.
Yeah,
of course I do.
So why don't you take more time?
I'd like to,
where's a good school?
There's gotta be a bunch of near you,
dude.
We,
anybody who can't find a good MMA or karate or anything school in MMA and a la
is crazy.
This is the spot.
Yeah,
I know.
I mean,
how many Goddamn Jujitsu schools are there,
Eddie?
How many 10th planets are there?
Just in La?
I'm going to 10 plants in the southern California area.
That does,
I went to,
yeah.
How many,
how many tenths plants are down here,
including San Diego or not?
Let's not include,
uh,
probably 10.
Isn't that amazing?
It's crazy.
It's amazing.
It's an almost a hundred worldwide guys,
man.
It's amazing.
I can't believe the Hashtag balling.
You earned it.
Yeah,
for sure.
It out.
You work hard.
You do work hard and you're innovative.
Thank you,
sir.
You're both,
you're an artist.
I don't think anybody gets by in this crazy competitive world unless you got
both.
You gotta.
You gotta be working hard and you gotta be thinking hard.
You gotta be creative,
but you also gotta be disciplined.
Oh,
full mind.
Full mouth your mouth though.
Ooh.
Ooh,
Oh,
beautiful.
Triangle triangle.
Real close.
Almost.
Almost so close.
So close.
Should be close.
Not quite there.
You got to get it all.
Now we're talking.
Now we're talking on bar now she's fucked.
Pay.
She fucked me the arm.
She's like eight out of 10 fucked.
She comes.
If you pulled your arm across your totally fine.
Now she's fucked more.
A lot of time here.
Oh yeah.
The arm bar option under the armpit or you pulled across and get the regular
triangle.
Oh,
he's got to pull her head.
Well,
Paige is doing right.
There was a good Moodle punch her in the face,
punched in the face.
Get that arm to come into the arm now just tell me Shit.
Fuck.
Fucking is a little animal
is Matt.
She's got to pull her head.
That's all covered.
I know now she should be thinking it's pulling or just telling her head,
pulling her head.
She's trying to get that on the other side,
you know?
Then now she's got,
she's got all the full wrap up.
Shit.
Wrap them.
Wrap it up.
Wrap it up tight.
She ain't gonna tap man.
I'm telling you.
This girl doesn't go to sleep.
She's not tapping.
You're gonna have to put her asleep.
Damn page is tough as shit.
Oh No.
Look at all the time.
37 seconds to go and she went to make it out of this fucking red time.
You've got time.
He's just an animal.
She hasn't had,
I'm so impressed with that girl.
I mean how many girls are as hot as her?
That her,
that fucking tough.
Yup.
Well what's going over the football?
I think they're both adorable.
Okay.
Someone's going to be.
That's because I'm an old man.
It's not as good.
And she's dropped and bows dropping the hard bows.
He's got to go the
triangle.
It's got an angle and finish and she's going to run out of town.
Oh,
oh,
am I going down?
Why isn't she pulling the head?
That's what she hasn't really committed to it.
No,
not no pulling in the head.
She was trying to do the legs.
She was trying to pull with the legs.
There was a Ben Saunders fight.
He fought a guy,
Brian Baker,
the fight that I called and he was doing like 10 different moves and you end up
losing that fight and at the end,
you know,
he's in the Middle East,
transitions,
whatever.
And,
and I think my broadcast part of the time goes,
man,
this is great transitions.
I go,
the problem is nobody taps to a toe hold triangle armbar risks lock.
It's the one you commit to.
And too many guys,
you know,
five transitions look as transitioning in,
but yeah,
but the one that gets you is the one you commit to all the way 100% and he
didn't do that enough.
They ended up rounding up,
going into losing the decision,
but if he chained to one and one stuck,
you'd be impressed by it.
Right.
That's all my other of whether whether or not once did I didn't see,
I didn't see that commitment to that one in a sense.
You know what I mean?
Like I think she had the armor and the triangle was kind of halfway with all of
them.
I think she just needed to pull the head if she has grabbed the back of the head
count and compare them to have faith in your triangle.
I told him,
I said,
have faith in your triangle.
Too many people go triangle it doesn't work in two seconds and they go to the
onboard and let the,
let the guy breathe again.
Commit to your triangle.
When you deal with someone like Paige vanzant.
It's the difference between trying to put someone asleep and trying to make
someone tap.
You can't try and make her tap.
You've got to try to put her asleep.
I really think that's what you got to do with her.
This little girl is a savage.
She's a little beautiful savage,
but she's down to rounds none to,
but she's still got those crazy switch kicks,
man.
She's super athletic with that shit too.
She goes from the outside and then she commits to these wild jumping roundhouse
kicks.
Damn guys,
I've got to run.
Oh,
you fucking fuck.
I know.
I gotta pick my family.
Well,
you gotta do what you gotta do.
How about you stay for 10 more minutes.
All right.
Thanks idea.
But I'm doing it.
That wasn't a hard sell either.
You went right for that.
You just gave right in.
Well,
I got to stay.
You're okay and watch this.
Yeah,
you just got to tell your family.
They can wait.
It's gonna have to wait on the curb.
Yeah,
you're in the year.
Tail wasn't safe to America.
Not In Guatemala.
Fucking beam got that flew.
I had asked us for 10 days.
We got a viral rash.
I had it to Jimmy who were doing our podcast.
I was coughing.
I'm done now when you're down for,
I was down for it.
I was down for two days.
But you know why?
Because I saw it coming.
Oh there's that jumping around house kicked.
I saw it coming and I was like,
you know what,
this is,
don't feel normal.
Right.
This feels like a little extra.
So you slept?
Yeah,
I just stayed in bed.
The beautiful thing of being self employed.
My son got it.
Fuck his friends.
Got his friend's,
mom's got Alex.
Yeah,
my youngest got it.
And she got over it and that day,
like a little wolverine.
My kids eat a lot of probiotics.
Man.
I got to meet and by okay.
And different probiotics and taking probiotic little snacks.
Fuck.
It makes a big difference.
So important.
I take too many of those.
I don't know.
Can you hear us talking about healthy food?
Have you heard of Sheila?
Jot The tar from um,
from the Himalayas.
It's loaded with trace minerals.
Sounds like it's from the Himalayas.
No,
we taste like garbage supposedly.
It's a shit.
She's got to be careful with that over and over and over again going to that
well without jumping round kick because if a girl's got a real good right hand
and she times that shit take you right after.
Yeah,
take you right off your feet and you're going to get fucking hurt because she's
throwing it and she's fully committing to it.
Meaning like she throws her arms into it so our hands are down.
Her Chin's up in the air like it's on a flag pole and it's a beautiful technique
of Atlanta.
But the problem is she,
she CalEd Beck wrong.
See She just tried to go do it again.
Like that well is tapped.
She's going to that well a lie hands are down too and she's kind of kick it.
She,
you know,
when she CalEd Beck Rawlings with it,
it was so sensational.
I think that's become like her shit.
You get hooked on it.
Hooked on that feeling I've seen all the time.
Yep.
Oh Nice.
Ooh.
Karch is much cleaner with the striking.
She's doing like basics,
technical basics,
and she's got a good timing with her right hand.
Clark's definitely had two rounds to know.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
See,
it goes again.
She's going to it again and you watch when she does it,
that left hand goes right down to her hips to fucking soak.
Dangerous.
She might be,
it's good every now and then,
but it,
Ooh,
right man.
He's just makes her pay every time she comes close with us.
If you're doing that against a man who is a kol artist,
oh,
almost landed that flying name.
Hey Dude,
she could land it,
but what I'm saying as she's making it very obvious that that's our goto shit.
She does it so often and it's an unusual move.
See,
she's tried to do it right there.
She takes his big step and then she tried to jump and throw around.
I mean,
who the fuck does a jumping routes?
Just two in a row right there.
Who the fuck does this that much?
Yeah,
you're Rodriguez.
No more than her hit me.
Then she does it more than him.
She does it more than anybody is like her go to shit as a jumping switch kick.
Like that's crazy.
I don't even care if that lands like,
just looks good.
It again.
Oh,
left hand behind it though.
It does look good.
At least she's doing something.
Yeah.
Well look,
she's going,
she's going after her and she's behind.
Yeah,
she's going after it.
She's trying to win by knockout Paige vanzant and presses his shit out of me.
She's,
she's tough.
And again,
just keeps coming up is a button.
Yup.
You know,
cute as a button on.
Oh Shit.
Fucking barbarian.
Yep.
Good athlete.
Good movement.
Eh?
Like why
didn't anybody see Claressa shields fight last night?
No page.
Santa has a broken arm right now.
She does what?
She told her corner after the first round.
Which arm must be the left,
right?
Yeah,
the left she's,
she's holding for.
Yikes.
Wow.
That's probably why she keeps throwing.
That's probably why she keeps throwing it.
Yeah,
it's definitely the left.
See how she's extended and she's not punching with it.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Ouch.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fucking nuts,
man.
She must've got kicked with something.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Still Game's still going at it alone for it.
Toughest fuck dude.
Well that makes sense now why she keeps going to the,
well with that jumping round kick.
That's,
that's what she's got from the left side.
Oh Damn.
Oh,
kick to the body.
It's a good scrap hall.
What's her name?
[inaudible] fundamentals,
ma'am.
Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking.
Oh,
it's her right arm.
Interesting to right arm.
Wow.
Owns in there.
She goes right to the Raj.
Remember Rich Franklin a truck with the [inaudible] clicking like turn it in.
Okay.
And K Odom and,
and even with a broken arm and split his lip open.
Remember that horrible injury.
Yup.
How have you guys got to go?
All right.
Nice meeting you.
See my brother friend.
Thanks for coming by.
Thanks for the cheese.
Thanks for the wine.
Of course.
I leave the wine here for you.
The next time we do a podcast,
come see me.
And uh,
where are you?
Columbus?
We're hilarious.
Funny,
right?
Count at the funny bone.
September of the best comics in the world.
25 26 27 then I'm in that at the DCM right here.
There are one,
two,
three new Columbus funnybone is fucking sensational because I hear it's one of
the best clubs going,
hey,
you know what they did?
They revamped it.
They moved the whole front bar area.
They took it out and expanded the showroom.
It's huge now.
Oh,
it's very nice.
Yeah.
Tell Dave I said,
what's up?
January 25 26 27 tall.
Beautiful.
Thanks guys.
[inaudible] fucking man.
I'm all,
I'll see that.
Brian cowen.com all that good stuff with a Y,
B,
r y.
Thanks brother.
Yeah,
just to leave it.
Just leave it there.
We got an answer.
They'll take care of it.
Very nice to meet you.
All right.
Say Heidi family,
brother.
We'll we'll do some history shit on the next podcast.
Loving man Brian.
Kaitlyn has to suddenly cares about their family more than they do about random
people listening to a podcast,
which is weird.
I mean different planets.
Oh Shit.
Fucking bullshit.
What are you talking you?
We hear you shut the door.
Was he trying to do,
he asked what the man,
he's like,
this is MMA,
right?
Brian Cowan is on a podcast that is about fighting the fighter and the kid and
barely pays attention to this board.
I mean it's like his,
his big Gig is him being on the podcast and it's half the fun.
Is Brendan going,
how do you not know this?
How do you not know this?
So Shab is home right now with the flu.
Is He?
Yeah,
that's why I called you.
I called it today.
He was in the backup.
That's cool.
Listen,
I'll call you again.
But he was going to be here and it was last minute.
He's like,
dude,
I'm too sick.
He was working in Portland and he's like,
I'm coughing so bad I can't do this.
I said,
my man Jimmy Smits around three now she meets him is so gangster later,
whichever.
I just want you to know.
He drives here in uh,
1968 Firebird stock.
Yes.
Fully stock stock seed stock breaks,
doc poses.
He's driving a 1968 car.
Like it's 1968.
That's my only car.
And that's how you get to also like how do they know that's all I drive it on.
That's very good.
Your mechanic?
No,
I just,
well I,
I like,
I can keep up with certain things,
but I'm on the road so much.
Even if I wanted to,
I couldn't,
like,
it would be in a garage all the time and that's very gangster.
But even before that and it got,
it got rear ended and I had to get it,
I need to get it replaced.
Yeah.
The 69 Barracuda is a beautiful year or two under appreciated year.
I had a 70.
And that's the bigger body.
It's a different one,
but in everybody knows that one.
Is that a head one?
Yeah.
And it's also like what the new challenge it looks like.
Right.
The new challenges,
like sort of a version of that.
But that older one is really unique in the muscle car world at 69 68 Barracuda,
it's a weirder shit.
Hard to find harder to find parts for a bed and to get the dash from like uh,
uh,
like a,
a junk yard in Hawaiian eye or some shit.
We know what they're doing.
It's really interesting.
Now a lot of companies are,
um,
there was a news company,
Steve Strope was just telling me about it,
that are making a 1969 Camaro from the ground up with all new parts,
making everything,
all the fenders.
They're making the subframe,
they're making the,
the,
the doors,
the dash panels,
like they're making a 1969 Camaro,
but it's not from 1969.
It's from 2018 I've heard crazy.
I've heard about people doing that same thing,
but the internal parts are all like eco friendly,
but it runs same frame and everything and the,
they're doing crazy shit and I've heard of that.
Yeah.
There's a Mustang that's like an 850 horsepower electric Mustang that someone in
Texas made and it's a 1968 Mustang,
but it's just some fucking beast fuck electric engine.
Wow.
Patrons.
And with a spinning back fist there.
Oh,
that's when she broke her arm.
Looks like,
oh wow.
She broke it on a spinning back fist.
That's,
that's crazy.
Fuck yeah.
These bones are weak as shit,
man.
Hey,
crack.
So easy.
Once again.
Tim Silvia.
Frank Mir.
Yeah.
Didn't and try to keep fighting.
I remember,
remember every Boone herb dean was so much like,
and then they saw the refit like,
oh,
okay,
yeah,
we got to point it out in the replay too.
We had to say slow it down.
Slow down.
What's that?
That's a broken arm.
Like that thing is not supposed to bend like that.
What was your worst on air in terms of like,
oh fuck moment.
Corey Hill and Anderson Silva,
those two leg breaks,
both of them feel worse because the referee didn't see it.
And so I threw my headset off and I jumped up and I was screaming,
stop.
The fight stopped the fight because the referee was in an odd position and the
leg,
he kicked the leg snapped.
I saw the Lego rubber.
I saw his lego down.
I saw him go down and then I forget who he was fighting was on top of him
hitting him and the referee wasn't,
it wasn't,
it wasn't on it.
He just wasn't aware.
He was in a bad position.
You know,
he's looking at the punches being landed.
He didn't realize that the leg had been snapped.
Those two were the worst.
There's Corey.
We did one.
It was,
oh,
I see.
So the referee calls over there and uh,
Corey Hill,
uh,
rest in peace.
He died.
Fears bag.
That ain't gone know.
Knock out of fucking,
oh,
so that's the UFC performance institute.
I went there two weeks ago when I was in Vegas.
Holy Shit.
Is that place impressive?
I mean,
have you been there Eddie?
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Amazing.
Did Tony Train there?
No,
I had a meeting at Ebi.
Meebo.
Right,
right,
right.
Oh,
nice.
Forest forest.
How amazing is that place did,
it's incredible.
It's one of the coolest places I've ever seen.
I was like,
oh my God,
I want to live here,
dude.
The screen where you can record your sparring and it's like an NFL thing where
you can write notes and circles and all this shit on it and give it to your
coach.
They were recording it in 360 degrees so they can look at you from any angle.
Yeah,
it's fucking incredible.
It's so cool.
And then they have all these different recovery stations.
They have a cryo machine that goes down to like 240 degrees below zero and then
up to 170 degrees above zero.
You can go hot cold inside the machine.
Like which is what the fuck.
It's crazy that like three pools of different temperatures for like,
well they have,
but they have two pools that are different temperatures.
One really hot one and run really cold one with their degrees.
And there's one your [inaudible].
That's my video.
Oh,
okay.
And then there's a treadmill to your left and a pool.
And that's Angela hills on that one right here while I'm filming.
And she's running their shoes.
Yeah.
And trust me with running on this treadmill that lifts,
lifts and lowers.
And you could watch your running form on these little screens.
Get a c I think.
Uh,
I think I cut to the screen.
She was joking around butter,
but you can check out the screen and you could see like your form to make sure
that your landing ball of the foot first,
you know,
with proper running form,
the fucking whole place is incredible.
They have sleep pods that you get in there,
like these lounge chairs and it's like some Scifi movie with his big ag comes
down over the Darth Vader.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The sleep pods.
So you line down there,
it's playing music and shit.
Dude off the charts.
I mean they have everything.
So last week I'm on your podcast and I can say it now.
You were talking about the performance center.
Well,
I had gotten a tour of that when I met Dana white and everybody like two weeks
ago.
So I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
yeah.
So anyway,
I got a tiny thing,
but it's kind of funny if you said yeah,
that seems familiar with that.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Yeah,
we were hoping that we were going to be able to imagine at the,
on the podcast,
but things take,
take time.
Paperwork,
man.
It takes,
it takes a minute.
Yeah.
And Hey,
congratulations to our boy.
Big John McCarthy.
Jacques Dude call him.
He'll be very good at that.
He's the new took over for me,
I felt.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He'll be great at that.
I think he's going to be awesome at that.
Um,
we're trying to work,
he's like,
I didn't know he was living in Vegas.
Yeah.
They moved.
Get tired of flying to Vegas all the time for fights,
so just fucking moved to Vegas.
That's the kind of guy big John Is.
He is man.
But he lives out in the burbs.
He's not like a on the Strip going to fucking hockey song every night.
Yeah.
I think he'll do a good job,
man.
I do know.
He'll be great.
He's really happy about that person.
Yeah,
he'll be great.
You know,
I mean,
you talk about a guy who's seen literally every major fight.
he was the go to guy for over a decade.
Like every big fight had to have big John McCarthy as a referee.
You know,
after a while a lot of guys have gotten like some of the calls for some of the
big,
big fights.
But yeah,
he's the gold standard and the guy knows so much about the sport and he's a
legit black belt.
He's not going to ref anymore now he's not gonna refer anymore for a while,
but he always could go back to it.
Do you know he's got two or three?
I might be at least two fake discs in his neck and then I think it might be
three and then he just got some shit fuse to Dale.
Yeah,
that Jujitsu is a motherfucker was a mother fucker and your joints man and
you're back.
You hear about so many people.
I got this thing I want to show you an every grappler should get one of these.
You should get one for the gym.
It's called an iron neck and it was created by a,
this guy who is a former football player and he created it to deal with CTE.
He's like a lot of what these guys are getting,
they're getting from their head getting snapped and he's like,
and I think you can mitigate a lot of that with neck strength,
but a lot of the different things that people create for neck strength.
This is him.
Show me how to do it.
We got one here,
so you strap this thing on your head,
you pump it up,
it's like a Reebok pump.
Remember those pumps?
We pressed it,
it gets real tight to your head and then you're pulling on that bungee cord.
That black cord is 50 pounds of resistance and so I'm pulling back and he's like
straightened out my posture and then there's resistance and turning the band
phenomenal.
I love that thing.
I love it.
How often do you do it?
Whenever I want to.
I have it.
I have one in my house and I have one here,
so I do it all the time.
I did it yesterday as part of my workout yesterday.
I still,
I like to start off my workout with it.
Um,
I put that fucker on and I go through a whole series of Stevie wonder's.
It was like you have it on your head and you go like this.
And what it does is,
you know,
he's real big on it.
Aaron Peko,
he loves that thing.
He said it turned his neck into a weapon.
You know,
and for me,
I had some pretty big problems with my neck for a while.
Um,
I think from,
uh,
two things from not tapping and two from head unarmed chokes,
cause I always,
I was doing a lot of head nom chokes on this side.
Oh,
is using,
you're always using your neck,
your neck becomes a part of your game.
And uh,
I never really strengthened my neck other than training.
And this,
this has made a big fucking difference.
Is that Johnny Hendricks?
So is that like a fact that it looks like Johnny Hendricks?
It's not Jonny Andrews.
Sorry,
fat guy.
You're not really fat,
Bro.
You're not fat.
You're not,
you're not ripped.
Like Michael Johnson,
but you're not fat.
I'm just talking shit.
But that machine,
um,
is like one of the best methods I've ever found of,
of strengthened in your neck.
Stabilizing your neck.
Edit that out about me calling that guy fat.
Sometimes you say things,
you just talk.
Yeah.
Just comes out of your mouth.
You know what I mean?
To forgot.
I'm going to say,
listen buddy,
I'm fat.
Um,
but this,
uh,
machine,
actually it's not fat at all,
but this machine is fucking phenomenal.
I just,
I'm a,
I'm a giant fan of it.
You can either have it on a bungee cord or some people put it on them.
Cable machines,
like out.
Imagine if you were some Frances and Ghana with fellow,
you would want even more resistance.
Oh,
that's an Austin.
They're doing that.
The,
uh,
the Onnit gym.
Um,
I'm a big fan of this thing and think every grappler in particular,
because how many people have fucking neck problems?
I mean,
to not have him as weird.
Yeah,
it is.
And I'm,
and I think this is a great machine,
but I think there's a bunch of other things you should do as well.
I'm a big believer in shrugs,
I think for,
for grapplers,
just protecting that whole area of building up all that muscle in the back area
and you get them fucking Overeem traps.
Remember Overeem?
Overeem?
Yeah.
Those believable,
they started at the top of his ear and was robbed down.
Yup.
You know what I got recently that,
um,
I'd like
to recommend is,
you know,
I have something really wrong with my right shoulder and I like to sleep on my
side.
So sometimes man,
I wake up in the middle of the night and my shoulder's sore just from sleeping
wrong on it.
It sucks putting all your weight on it.
And after a while fucking and I got the flu like you did too.
I got it last week for a day.
I was in bed for 24 hours and man,
my shoulder was killing me from being sick in bed.
So I got this pillow that's for people that have acid reflux.
It's,
it's a sloped pillow and there's a hole in it where you could put your arm under
and you sleep on the side.
I'm in love with it.
I've seen it.
It's called,
it's called Med Klein,
Maggie Klein.
It's awesome.
And you could see both,
both sides.
And there's like this snake pill that goes through it.
So your arm is feeling beautiful.
There's no pressure on it and you're on your side.
Um,
oh look at that.
That's it.
That's a weird looking dude.
I'm telling you.
I'm in love with this thing,
man.
It's incredible.
No Shit.
Yes.
I think maybe that's a big part of my shoulder problem.
Maybe I'm thinking cause like,
yeah,
just like I sleep on my side and I know that you're not supposed to,
you supposed to sleep flat on your back.
I cannot sleep flat on my back.
I gotta be on either side.
I'm always switching to one side to the next.
Well when you,
you started lifting heavy again,
um,
after you got those cortisone shots,
you said her shoulder was feeling amazing.
Yeah.
And then you told me you were doing bench.
I was like,
like batches,
one of the worst things for your shoulds,
I should have never got a cortisone shot.
That was the big mistake right there.
I got talked into it by a doctor I wanted,
I went into the doctor to get a prescription for an Mri and I told them what I,
you know,
my shoulder's been,
just doesn't heal.
It's just constantly bothering me.
And he did a couple tests and he said,
hey,
you don't have any tears,
but what's wrong is you're the tendon that's connecting your bicep to your
shoulder.
It's thrashed.
But if we put a cortisone shot in there,
you'll be fine.
And I grew up a big football fan and I always thought cortisone shots,
but an athlete takes,
you know,
for,
to play the rest of the game.
But he's going to pay for it afterwards.
But just to get through the game,
give them a cortisone shot.
I thought it was just a painkiller and that's what I told him.
And he said,
no,
it's a big myth that it actually heals the tendon.
And I,
I said,
really?
okay.
So he did it.
He said,
don't do shit for 10 days.
I didn't.
Then it,
it actually did,
it felt amazing.
And then I started lifting again and I started lifting heavier than ever.
And then about,
uh,
and dude,
like all the time I started doing your little,
uh,
that routine you were talking about.
Some Russian said that you're supposed to do the,
the same body parts,
like,
uh,
not just once a week,
but like,
you know,
every time you go in and hit the same body parts,
just don't hit them that hard.
Remember that preceded the groove.
Yeah.
So that's what I started doing.
But then I started doing DH,
working the same body part every time I went to the gym,
the gym,
I did chest hard every time I went to the gym back hard.
Every time I went to the gym I was doing a complete body workouts.
It just slowly morphed into that.
And I always want her to go to failure.
And then within two months the pain started coming back and then it just slowly
progressed.
And now it's worse than ever.
So I'll never get an MRI.
Yeah.
And I am.
I am.
I just got the prescription for that last week.
All I gotta do is go in.
Now I'm going to go get that checked out.
And it's such a common injury,
you know so many guys.
But that pillow though was helping.
That pillow is huge.
I'm going to get one that's interesting.
Looks Awesome.
All right.
We're about to hit the main event.
Jeremy Stevens just showed up.
Oh Shit.
Jeremy Stevens,
he's a tough fucking out at 145 pounds.
That's a big 45 or,
I mean,
he's fucking big for that weight class
and he's coming off of that fight against,
who the fuck did he just fight?
He had a real good fight against a veteran where he kicked the shit out of his
legs.
I want to say Jim Miller.
No,
but that would be 55 13 first round
finishes,
right?
Seventh by knockout second.
Most of knockdowns in UFC history.
He's an animal.
He's the best.
So he beat Gilbert Melendez.
Knockdowns in UFC history.
Crazy.
That's incredible.
He's a fucking animal.
I remember his prior Kao of Dos Anjos.
Yeah.
Stunning.
Upper cut.
Boom.
Next snap an uppercut.
He's a fucking animal.
Dennis Bermudez at flying knee against the cage.
Jeremy Stephens,
honey,
Jason,
that head kick.
Woo.
He's got a ton of a man.
That's his thing.
It's a fucking animal.
I'm excited about this fight too.
Cause do Ho Troy brings it and he's got a clean right hand.
That right hand comes down the pipe like a piston.
Isn't he going to the Korean army though for awhile?
No,
no.
That's a chance on John the Korean Zombie.
He went two years.
No Korean.
He came by.
This guy's got,
he's going to,
well
maybe I'll do eventually.
Wow.
That's a bummer for guys that are like world class fighter.
They should think they should give him a little break.
You know,
let him put that shit off.
Nope.
Two years baby sacrifice.
Do Ho choice.
Here we go baby.
It is,
uh,
it is,
I mean,
uh,
from uh,
a ruler standpoint.
It's actually a great idea.
I make everybody go to the army for two years,
right?
It's not a bad idea if you want to instill patriotism and people too.
And,
and understanding of like what it means to have a country,
you know what is,
what does it mean to have an armed service if you're just some soft fat,
little pudgy fuck.
Like me sitting back letting the soldiers do all the work.
You actually have to go and do it yourself and you're actually over there.
Oh,
they gotta worry about is North Korea.
That's it.
No one else is messing it down.
Well China,
China's on the side of North Korea.
That's part of the problem.
That's a part of our problem with negotiating clear war.
Most people don't know North Korea and South Korea,
they signed a cease fire.
They never signed an armistice,
so then there's no peace treaty.
They just will stop fighting for right now.
I didn't help Hawaii the other day.
Yeah.
What the fuck man,
I done fucking with us.
Kelly Slater's Instagram.
I was like what?
There was a fake nuclear or a fake missile warning that a missile was coming in
and they said it was not a drill,
like how was that a wrong button kind of thing.
Like go through a few people before it goes out to the whole state and getting a
phone call and you have the option to like say,
Hey,
I'll call you back.
I'm driving.
You know,
like it's one of the two or three options that you could just press.
Yeah.
Is one of them.
Hey,
and intercontinental ballistic missiles heading your way.
Hawaii.
It's like,
oh,
here's weather,
here's missile and you hit the wrong.
No,
it shouldn't work that way.
Shouldn't be anywhere near like that.
And lots to the whole state it us too.
Yeah,
I know.
Legally Mcfarland,
who was on her Instagram,
I was like,
yeah,
apparently is a mess hall.
It's the same shit.
I was unbelievable.
People were fucking crying and freaking out.
Apparently I have a friend who lives in Hawaii,
you know that's a state that's been hit before.
If I can,
I literally,
yeah.
Right,
so you gotta think mean memory of Pearl Harbor.
This is people who were alive back then.
Plenty of them.
Okay.
Jeremy,
mother fucking Steve,
dom,
dom.
This should be war.
I am very excited about this.
Okay.
There's certain guys who don't know how to have a boring fight and Jeremy
Stevens is one of those guys.
Yeah,
he's one of them.
He's a fucking animal and he,
he's looking forward to this fight to stylistically and a lot like the Gilbert
Melendez fight.
Yeah.
I don't think it was another guy.
I want to see if he goes right back to that same low calf kick.
He had so much success with it in that Melendez fight.
I mean that essentially took Melendez out of his game plan real early.
He looks like such a wolf would that crazy beard.
Okay.
Never went boxing.
Didn't let guys have beards.
The fuck was out about or bitching about Canelo's hair when he fought a triple g
interest in it.
As long as barriers,
too long and it softens a punched Ia.
I don't buy that at all.
Seems so ridiculous.
That was like something that they used to say like you used to have to shave
your beard.
Oh,
sound style.
It's a big pad.
Ooh,
duo Choi land is too hard.
Leg kicks in a row.
I just can't imagine it realistically softening up punch to make a difference.
And I mean,
I kind of see,
I have to show me something.
Maybe Kimbo slice beard because he had that thick hair.
Oh,
there's a nice one.
Bye Jeremy.
Dual choice tall for
the weight class man at five 10 and a half,
one 46 golden.
Nice.
This is,
uh,
you know,
people complain about weight cutting all the time when,
we've talked about it many times,
but you see how big these fuckers are.
You see why they do it.
I mean,
it's crazy.
If you can do it,
it's worth it.
What's interesting is what California is doing.
You know,
there's a bunch of guys like Marlin,
like Marlin Mariah's,
they,
they essentially,
they're not saying that he can't fight one 35 again,
but they're saying,
dude,
you're 145 pound fighter who's killing themselves to make one 35 Ooh,
another one by choice.
So do Ho choice.
Having mow right hand over the top I two O ne by choice.
Oh Shit.
He looks clean.
Yeah.
Chin's up.
He,
oh,
he was relying a lot on its ability to read punches.
Was Jenna.
Hi.
Yeah.
Maybe
how do they decide if someone misses wait in a certain way category two or three
times then automatically?
Well,
that's a good way to do it.
Just no,
there's no hard fast rule in terms of like how the UFC approaches it.
It varies depending upon the individual circumstances.
But with California,
Andy Foster,
who's the head of the Athletic Commission in California is in my opinion,
one of the very best in the world.
He's real proactive,
is super on top of things.
He,
and he's instituted a bunch of different weight classes.
They,
they've added 65 75 they're,
they're adding more weight classes,
which I think is critical.
I think that's the future.
I really think we,
we spent way too much time with 20 pound gaps in between.
Oh,
Jeremy's Davis tags them two in a row.
Yeah.
Oh,
and then a good leg kick as well.
I think we spent way too much time with a minimal amount of weight classes with
these eight weight classes.
I think we could use more.
And,
um,
what they've decided is that if a fighter is a certain weight,
when they weigh in,
they can only be a certain weight more when they fight.
So they're weighing guys when they weigh in and then they're weighing them right
before they fight.
And guys like Marlin,
he gained a Shitload of weight.
I think he gained 17 pounds.
Sorry if I'm wrong,
but I think it's somewhere in the neighborhood of 17 pounds,
which they were like,
get the fuck out of here with that.
So what happens when you show up the day of the fight and you were 20 pounds
over?
What did they do?
I don't think they do anything yet.
I think they're recommending you move up.
So the real problem would be what?
What would happen if Marlin Mariah's won the title at 135 pounds?
Which he's world class.
I mean that's,
that's a real,
that's certainly a possibility.
It's not out of the realm,
the realm he's going to be fighting if everything keeps going well for him,
the way they aljamain sterling knockout was he's going to wind up fighting for a
world title.
And I think it's a great fight for teaching a world title at one 35 then your
one 35 on that title.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean he made it.
Right.
But the UFC and you know also the California State Athletic Commission,
even Nevada now they're trying to do something which I think is important to do
something about these fucking heavyweight.
We'll talk about this fight,
this fight.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it's really good.
Well,
somewhere they were talking about if you,
if you,
if you missed,
wait,
you weren't allowed to fight at that weight class for your next fight.
I don't remember where they were.
They were talking about doing that.
That,
that's smart too.
That was,
yeah,
that was a planet heard.
That's where you're the commissioner,
uh,
George Lockhart or a dolce or someone who has a wealth of it by choice.
Woo.
Jeremy Stevens could take it to,
that's the thing about it.
She has a tendency to come forward when he's hurt.
He just wants to throw more.
He wants to get you back.
Yeah.
He's not a recoup and,
and,
and figure it out kind of guy.
He wants some payback.
He's a fucking savage.
That's why he's so fun.
He's,
he's looking for something though.
He gets creative in there though.
I mean he'll,
Ooh,
Snappy Jab by choice.
Choi has got some clean technique.
Men.
Ooh.
Firefight and good foot work by Choi to,
oh he goes to the body,
goes the body with that left hook
and he invites him in by keeping the hands just low enough to bait Jeremy
Stevens in.
But he's reading the punches really,
really well.
He keeps tagging that fucking left leg.
Stevens set.
Last one.
One strong hold stuff.
Ooh,
this is a five round or two right?
Of course.
Must Be.
Yeah man,
it ain't event.
That's a weird argument,
right?
Like what do you like when they changed the main events to five rounds,
not just world title fights,
right.
Main events like that.
Yeah,
like a rounds.
The better.
Yeah.
I have more five round fights.
Definitely get you thinking.
Look,
you'll,
you'll figure out who the fuck is the best fighter because oftentimes things
start getting weird around the fourth round.
But fighters make the argument,
I've heard this argument before,
like you only have so many five round fights in your body.
Yeah.
And when you're using them up on these,
uh,
fights where you're trying to get to a world title,
like by the time you get there,
those fourth and fifth rounds are there.
They're taking a toll on you.
It could,
we could potentially see guys with a shorter careers because of that.
Yeah.
When also thinking about what goes into a camp for a five round fight,
I mean,
it's five rounds harder for eight weeks,
10 weeks,
and you're starting to get into,
I had this camp for a five round fight.
So the camp itself is harder to,
and you only know,
we only have so many those in yet.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no arguing that a boxing,
you know,
it used to be 15 rounds and they went,
those last three.
Yeah.
Really a killer.
Well,
I think it was that Dr. Kim.
That was the fight,
right?
Ray?
Boom,
boom.
Manzini what a fight that was.
And that was another weight cut issue.
Yup.
That was back when they used to make them way in the day of the fight.
Yeah.
Ooh,
front kick to the face.
Yup.
Referee committed suicide.
Did he really?
Is He did God damn.
Which referee was that?
I that,
that I don't,
I don't remember his name.
And I know he took his life.
Oh Man.
Already got suicide to the body.
Oh.
Jeremy Stephens with a right knee left knee.
Shit rolls like Chevy stole something from him.
Jeremy.
It's rose hay makers.
He ticked,
he tagged them with that right hand.
Who the fuck is more savage than Jeremy Stephens?
Not many.
Oh,
switch elbow.
That bald by choice.
Nice.
Looked like a jab,
then turned it over
and a leg kick for strong leg kick by choice.
Well,
and a lot of people would hesitate at this point to throw that many leg kicks
when the guys got a right hand like that.
And he's not hesitating.
No.
He's like the really prepared well to avoid it and to counter make them pay in
that long,
long stiff jab of his helps to get a little of reach advantage as well.
Jeremy.
I think Jeremy's five,
eight and a half inch and a half
taller,
maybe two inches tall.
Ooh.
Oh,
beautiful timing with that right hand.
Snapped his head back.
Ooh.
Nice Jab to there,
Jeremy.
Jeremy getting that timing down.
Choice taking it well though.
Yup.
Well he took a while and that cub Swanson,
he took a hard leg kick there too.
Now he's tied.
Starting to turn a little bit of walking him down.
He's walking him down,
switching legs and looking for those big shots,
throwing,
throwing some offspeed punches to close the distance.
I think a couple of checklists would be good for them.
Choice coming in once again with that head straight on.
Okay.
But Steven's just loves walking forward,
man.
But he's such a fucking animal.
Yeah.
I mean he just loves these firefights that the opportunity to test who's the
tougher guy and especially at one 45
oh right.
Might be it.
That was good.
Good.
Leaping shot.
Staying with the left hand.
Oh,
Don Donald.
That's done it.
Oh my God.
Wow.
What a fucking writing is an animal.
Oh,
broke that guy's back and go.
That guy's fucked.
Who is that guy?
His
Dad.
Oh,
he's playing it off.
Oh Man.
That's beautiful.
Whew.
What a fight too.
Huh?
But as soon as that tide turned,
as soon as he felt like I can walk through these punches,
it was over.
Yeah.
Fucking animal is a savage.
He's such a savage,
Jeremy.
Steve,
it's great stuff,
man.
Fuck.
That was awesome.
Ooh.
And he could do that to anybody.
That's the thing.
He takes it so well and his,
that attitude that he's got that fucking ferocious attitude.
Now here's what's really impressive.
When you think about choice war with cub Swanson and think Jeremy Stevens just
smashed him inside a two.
It's impressive to that.
He got front kicked in the face,
Kinda.
It was almost like a crest and kick took him on the side.
Boom,
right hand boom,
snapped him back with that one.
That was the beginning of [inaudible].
That was the,
the head snap or that was it.
And that one over the top.
He caught him right on the temple and his legs go and boom,
look at that.
Jesus Christ.
Here's the one.
That's the big one.
Oh my goodness.
Boom.
That was great.
Boom,
boom.
Good job.
Fuck.
Hell yeah.
Good stuff man.
It's good fucking fight.
My boys is always going to be that guy didn't just toss bag over rat right hand.
Uh,
what was it?
King Mo.
Seth Petrocelli.
Do you see that one?
He cleared his legs and bombed them and out.
I mean eyes wide shut was crazy.
Now he fought Max Holloway,
correct?
Stephens.
Yeah,
probably.
I feel like my Max Holloway beat him.
Clear decision.
See if you pull it up.
I think Max Holloway beat him on the way up to the title.
You know,
it was a good fight too for Holloway.
He really avoided all Jeremy Stephens.
Yeah,
there you go.
Max.
No Max Holloway decision.
Unanimous three rounds.
But that was in 2015 a little over three years ago to December of 2015.
Um,
interesting.
You know,
got think with a Kol like that.
He's like one,
maybe two fights outside of another possible shot or a possible shot at Max.
Now that Max has the title.
I liked that.
I liked that a lot.
Very interesting.
But once again,
I always fun to watch.
He's a fucking always him.
Yeah.
I don't always watch him so much fun.
So,
um,
next week is the big world title fight the heavyweight division.
And what,
what does the undercard looked like?
Jamie?
Pull up the full under card for a Francis and gone oh versus steep.
Amy.
Oh chick.
I think this is like the most important heavyweight title fight that I can
remember.
I don't remember a heavyweight title fight that people are biggest one in a long
time because what's going on steep.
It has the history side.
He has the,
I can be the greatest of all time or amongst them and uh,
yeah.
And if he could turn it on,
it was so scary.
Yeah.
The last time I think I was disinterested in the fight was um,
junior dos Santos versus cane one.
It was a lighter,
right.
Oh,
here it is right there.
I'm an idiot.
Yeah.
Here we go.
So we got Steve Bay versus Francis,
the main of it all.
Daniel Cormier versus Volk on owes demeanor.
Ooh,
that's interesting.
There's Volkov like he got a quick ride to the title,
you know,
I um,
he beats OSP and a real close decision,
knocks out,
circle off,
then knocks out Jimmy Manawat whenever it is like holy Shit,
three fights in and then boom,
next fight.
It's fighting core me.
It's just the way he was able to knock out Manoa and so corn off people like
listen,
let's see it.
And also,
I mean it's division where there was room for that new guy and he was the right
guy.
It,
we've seen it a million times.
The right guy at the right time,
right guy at the right time.
And uh,
by all accounts in the gym,
he was one of the only guys that was sparring with rumble on a daily basis.
Yeah,
he's rumbles main guy,
which is,
that says a lot.
Oh yes,
I,
he does.
Ron was talking about coming back as a heavyweight.
Check out the shot right here.
Oh No,
I didn't show it.
That was before.
Yeah.
The,
the one big one,
the big one to us.
They showed the big shop but they didn't show it.
Set it up.
Here it is.
Boom.
That was nice.
Yeah.
And then the big one is we throw it to the side.
Nope.
Stands up.
Chucks him to the site.
Ah.
Just cause they know you're a
lefty through the left leg or his left arm on the right leg.
Fuck yeah man.
I feel like he's a at the top of the heap now.
So who else we got here?
Um,
interesting.
The big fights,
the two big fights,
obviously the light heavyweight title in the heavyweight title,
which is really rare that you have.
I'm so out that mixed with the UFC.
Most of that car and I don't know any of those fighters.
Like half the bottom half of that main card.
I know Thomas Almeda.
That's it.
Yeah.
There's so many guys.
Man.
Rob Font and Thomas I met is a good,
again,
that's very interesting.
And Rob Fonts,
a Boston guy too.
He's wanting to,
della [inaudible] guys.
That should be a lot of fun.
So Jimmy Smith,
when's the first time they have you working?
Well,
I'm doing the pre and post for two 20.
Okay,
so you're in California,
the California here at Fox and then um,
they have,
they've,
they've offered me a couple and I've accepted them,
but they haven't announced it yet,
so I don't know.
Oh,
it's nothing official yet.
Okay.
But soon,
soon as the best way to put it,
they just color,
I'm assuming they just trust you or you don't have to do any bullshit like test
shows or anything like that because I've heard a guy where I've heard of guys
doing test shows,
they try people out and shit.
Not that I'm aware of.
No.
I mean it's already,
yeah,
I mean obviously you know what the fuck you're doing.
I would imagine that though the real hard Gig,
it's gotta be finding when then play by play guys.
That doesn't annoy the shit out of you.
But no,
seriously,
that's a real job.
Like that.
Colors,
colors,
easy doing play by play.
That's a real job.
They do a lot more of those anchor was that the different skin color and play by
play is is we're specific.
A particular sport
and we can call grappling and combat sports and whatever.
A play by play guys do.
I'll do basketball one week and then hogs and then this and then it's a job,
but there are a lot more of them.
You can go,
okay,
he's good at basketball and soccer.
You can see a body of work before they jump in because a lot of times it's we
need a guy who knows a sport and there are only so many.
Yeah,
it's a very different job,
very different skillset,
but people get real
angry if you don't know MMA.
If you're like a play by play guy and you say some goofy shit and you don't
really know the sport
they do,
they free and they'll forgive you either they don't.
If they don't think you really know the sport or really love the sport,
those two things are critical.
You have to really know it and really love it.
Or though,
otherwise they're like,
fuck you hated me when I,
when I compensated for king
stupid.
Oh,
we show how to say Sarah.
He just did it.
They just showed it,
showed the big Jeremy Stephens haymaker
I socked.
Oh my God.
Well that was terrible.
You think of it as a,
you know what you were really good at.
You were really good as the guy in between the rounds that was explaining who
won the fight.
Like when you,
you and I,
people don't even remember this,
but we worked together.
Uh,
it would be Goldberg and me and then for a bunch of cards you would be beside us
car guy.
Yeah.
So he had,
but anyhow,
had a real system.
Like we talked about it and I was like,
how are you doing this?
And he had like a really well thought out system where he had a line down,
a piece of paper and he had a bunch of categories and he had all these different
things,
whether it was takedowns are key.
And so he marked all these things on top of watching the fight.
A wanted to know,
like we'll be able to look down on it like,
oh he landed all these right hands.
Yeah,
I could look at the end of the fight.
They go to me.
I have to talk about what happened in the first though.
I gave him the second,
cause remember that second he had to take downs.
But if I didn't write it down I would forget.
Yeah.
So as I'm waiting to go on,
I'm revealing that first round I remember,
you know,
it's,
it's a lot easier to see what,
what actually happened cause you forget or anyways,
I do,
I would forget unless I wrote it down.
The funniest thing to me are the most frustrating thing to me is they wanted me
to do scorecards,
calling unofficial score card,
you know,
whatever.
Just like you did.
And I would do it.
And every time I never wrote down a number without explaining what I was talking
about.
I gave it tonight as close round,
but I gave it because of this,
this and this.
And people would always act like you just threw out a fucking number without
saying anything.
What was he thinking?
I said,
what I was thinking,
I never just wrote down nine 10.
I always said,
and here's why.
Here's you may disagree,
but here's my logic behind what I'm saying.
You can disagree with me.
Fine.
But the people that act like I just write down a number without explicit.
It's insane.
I'm just,
I'm so not going to miss it.
Commentators
post fight interviews once I said,
congratulations to Randy couture.
I said,
congratulations,
chuck.
I said that,
and when I walked out of the octagon,
uh,
who was it?
Joe Silva goes,
Dude.
He said,
congratulations,
chuck.
I said,
watch,
watch.
Oh my God,
I'm going to get fired.
I thought I was going to get fired right there.
And I went up to John.
I said,
dude,
did I say congratulations,
chuck?
He goes,
you go,
yes.
I'm like,
oh no.
This is my last show.
I totally thought I was getting fired by 100% I can talk about this because we
joke about it.
We joked about in belt of it,
but uh,
uh,
Jen Brown,
one time we were in and it was alive.
It was a live piece was just to the house so it didn't go out on air or
anything.
It was just for the house.
She and Brown football,
Jim Brown,
Jim Brown does extend them stuff for,
okay.
We were in,
uh,
that could fill Oklahoma and she said,
we had been in Kansas the week before.
She goes,
Hey Kansas and the place,
there's what are pretty,
she goes,
you know that they really didn't,
they really didn't react much.
And she and the guy goes,
you sit Kansas,
we're in Oklahoma.
And
we always joke about,
I love jam.
But yeah,
for weeks it was,
what state are we in jail?
We did me forever.
But it was just an inhouse piece.
It didn't go out on TV and he was hilarious.
Lucky.
No,
no.
All done knows we've all messed up.
People were talking,
Shit,
I've called over a thousand fights.
I've fucked up a bunch of dog,
man.
The brain,
the human brain just doesn't work perfect.
You make mistakes sometimes,
which drives me crazy is I have a very good recall for fights and for scenarios
and positions of people been in and ways guys won.
But occasionally there'll be a guy and I can't remember his fucking name and
it's like weird.
It's,
but it's a guy that I've seen fight.
Oh,
like Jorge Mazda dollar,
someone like that.
But I see him fight a hundred times,
like,
how the fuck do I,
why isn't that one coming out?
It's like the brain is just not a perfect vehicle.
It just doesn't always work.
Right.
It's like a range rover.
They look beautiful,
but range rovers work most of the time.
You know what I'm saying?
I have a friend who has a range rover and I asked him,
I said,
hey,
do you like that guy?
He's like,
yeah,
this is my second one.
My last one was a lemon.
I fucking knew it.
And he's like,
but it's a great car.
It's amazing when it drives pleasing.
That's like how a brain is.
It's not always good.
So you saying congratulations,
chuck,
and then leave and you're like,
oh,
watch fights.
Not necessarily yours of course,
but I'll watch somebody calling the fight and I'll know when they spaced on the
name,
they'll still start going,
you know that because you're watching you go,
he spaced on his name,
Dude.
It's sometimes that we basketball,
football,
whatever,
but I'll go,
I'll know as a broadcaster,
I'm like,
he he space.
He looked at his notes and he got the name back,
but he's spaced on the fucking name and it has some possible hundred percent
happens all the time.
My big fear is that I'm going to be interviewing a fighter after a fight and
then I can't remember their name when I congratulate them.
The biggest fear Bro,
I all I know that's not just you do,
that's fine too.
Before I go out there,
I will write it like if it's a dude I've never seen quite before,
like maybe one by first round knock out.
I've never seen him fight before.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Who is this guy?
He might've come from,
you know,
CFA or something like that.
I'll write his name down,
I'll read it.
I'll say it back.
I'll repeat you.
You might see me walking to the stage to the cage and I got my earpiece in and
I'm saying,
you know,
blah blah blah blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
I'm saying his name.
I don't want to fuck it up.
You are not alone though.
Do that fear is huge because you're thinking about question Tim cause you'll see
him on what to ask them and what well we on Aaron,
we saying this,
we were talking about interviewing fires is a literally the hardest part of the
job because lot of time to prepare for it.
No,
you have time to ask him one,
maybe two questions that said no.
Everyone has their own question in their own head that they want to ask.
And if you don't come up with something entertaining or creative,
um,
you know,
people talk shit on you.
It's all dude.
Yeah.
It's also very important.
This is what I tell people that are just trying to now for the first time and
then anybody,
any young people that are thinking about getting into MMA commentary.
You're the,
you're not the show like you,
you are,
you are just trying to extract information out of this person.
Like your question should be just to lead them.
I try to have as little personality and those things as possible.
I'm just trying to just give you the platform.
I'm just trying to give you maybe a path to take your answer.
Um,
I saw some beautiful things happen in the fight.
I want to,
I want you to express what happened in your mind or maybe there's some adversity
that you had to go through.
I want to know how bad it was,
but I don't want to be there.
I'm just,
I'm just the guy that has to say those words.
Yeah.
They hate it.
I never enjoyed that shit.
The flip side of that though,
that I've run into personally,
um,
you know,
overdoing it too is if your question isn't it
a eat,
you know,
hey,
great performance tonight,
man.
He,
if it's too open and a lot of times they go,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Right.
If you don't ask him something a little specific,
they'll just kind of go,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
if you don't say,
oh great,
you know that tired,
they're out of breath.
It's that you want them to go wherever they want to go.
But also if you don't ask something specific enough,
sometimes they'll go,
yeah,
it was how shitting your pants.
Cause my person was with a translator.
Oh,
those are rough back and forth.
But honestly sometimes
gives you more time.
I always try to talk slow and give them something.
I try to simplify what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But I even then,
I still,
sometimes I fucked that up.
You know?
It's just,
it's one of the weirder job.
Yeah.
I never liked it.
I never liked that at all.
I never really liked commentating.
I tried to get DC when DC was doing it because DC was doing a few of them.
Like we were doing it and I go,
oh,
that's your job now,
bro.
He's like,
you're doing that Joe Rogan get in there.
I go,
no,
no man,
I'm a,
you're doing a good job.
But like sitting here,
I'm gonna just get to sit back and I was like fuck that.
Cause he was doing like the the fight pass prelim ones.
Unless you're in the industry,
you'd be surprised at how many people don't realize that there's a play by play
guy and a color.
They just see two dudes talking.
They don't know.
I didn't know I was a grown ass man when I first got offered the job for King of
the cage.
I didn't know the difference.
I just thought,
yeah there's two dudes to old dudes talking to.
They're just chit chatting.
I didn't see the system in the and the owner of the real problem though.
The problem in MMA is that the color guy is the martial arts experts and the
football,
but the play by play guy,
it's just the news guy is just the guy.
But the play by play guy in sports is kind of calling what's happening as well.
He's saying,
you know,
they're moving the ball,
they're doing this,
they're going,
this,
this formation is,
but when you're calling a fight,
especially when the fight goes to the ground,
that play by play guys not really saying anything.
Right?
Yeah.
He could say he's in the mount,
in the mount taking big shots in the amount.
You don't have to be an expert to know a little bit,
but he's basically,
he's like,
like when Golde Goldie and I had a great rhythm cause Goldie like kind of laid
off when it,
especially when it would go to the ground,
he would lay off and he would just sort of like,
you know,
he would set me up like he'd say any moves into the mount position or he would
say,
you know,
something like that.
And then he would just lay it up for me and then I would elaborate on the
progression of techniques and where they were at.
Is he supposed to do that?
Um,
that's the hardest motherfucking job ever.
I didn't know.
So I get this job,
but Brotzmann he takes over the production part of King of the cage and he wants
to use me as a commentator cause we went to the producer and I went to John
Jacques Machado Academy.
He knew me as the NNA fanatic guide and he asked me if I wanted to commentate
and I said,
yeah,
fuck,
I'll try it.
I didn't know shit.
Those first king of the cages,
he didn't know that there was a difference between a play by play and color guy.
The producer didn't know the difference because once I started really listening
to the broadcast and the UFC,
I started listening to the opening and how they opened shit.
I go,
oh,
there's two jobs here.
This guy's,
this guy is just a news telecaster and this other guy's the expert didn't even
really realize it.
I thought they were both experts and just talk.
I thought,
I thought there were two different jobs so that yes,
exactly.
Once I realized that I talked to,
but I said,
hey,
listen,
there's two jobs going on to be the play by play guy.
I want to be the color guy.
He said to both.
You're going to do both.
I go all sports don't have guys that do both.
He have a color guy and you have a play by Buicks.
One to the producers.
Just the to the,
to the producer.
Okay.
I just want it to the first that does a gun.
He'd never done sports before so he didn't understand.
He just said,
dude,
you're going to do both.
Both of you.
Me and Don the dragon.
Wilson.
We were done
in there.
Winging it.
It was so bad.
What's terrible up to these days?
I have no idea.
But those,
those are some of the worst shows.
Yeah.
Ever for commentary.
First of all,
I want it so hard.
It was so bad.
Oh my God.
You did it or some shit for pride to
five 10 pride.
10 with the Hanzo and Sakuraba when handled got his arm broken.
You're got headbutted by Vandelay Silva.
You were saying that so that soccer,
I would never go to submit Hanzo.
Yes.
That was one of the biggest blunders ever.
Soccer.
Robert has to come in and they're standing and I said,
[inaudible]
I,
I'm in the commentary.
I said,
that may work at his gym,
but that turns out Gracie,
it's never going to work on him.
And then boom,
he breaks his home
on cue.
I call
work here.
There was a guy,
ed west,
ed wild west was fighting and he had never knocked anybody out.
Really good striking.
But like,
you know,
pitter pat can all striker.
And I literally said,
man,
eds land and great but not a knockout guy.
And he instantly knocks him out first one of his career right there,
right in front of him.
Like he did that just to make me fucking look stupid.
Thanks.
That's what it happens on the job,
man.
You can never,
it's almost like the universe is punishing you for Hubris.
Like you're pretending you know more than you do this.
No,
just shut the fuck up.
Say it looks good.
It's deep.
There was,
yes,
seriously.
Get that habit of going.
Who knows?
Probably will
one fight for an endo.
Boskin cellos fought this one guy and he schooled him yet
got above
one of the great guy.
Great.
You never really did it.
Fuck crazy to communicate.
Remember that key was good.
Carl fucked him up,
didn't he?
Yeah,
Carl one.
And he in a fight that he won because he won I think two straight.
He was,
he had good hands and he wrestled and um,
uh,
he had a guy,
he passed,
guys guard had them in north south and I said,
this position is called a,
some people call it north south,
but if you look at an old judo books,
it's actually called the tea bag.
And then I just kept going and don the dragon eggs.
I never stopped her and I would just throw it away.
That's how we're talking about
seriously.
And Bud loved it.
The Terry Terry triple cop,
the owner hated it.
He hated it.
But,
but loved it.
The producer
love them.
Every now and then.
I would say some crazy wild shit.
But Terry hated and the director,
no,
no.
Terry loved it.
What am I saying?
The director Steve,
he hated it.
He was begging me to stop because I wasn't renters.
Yeah.
That wasn't being unprofessional,
but nobody,
but the owner didn't care.
He loved it.
So,
um,
anyways,
I sucked regardless.
But
I'm a retired,
we're all in the right spot where we want to be.
I'm not born to connotate.
That's not my thing.
Like now when people offer me jobs,
like I'm like,
I don't want to commentate.
I want to just enjoy the fight and just watch with literally no.
When I said to Dana,
when he forced me into doing it,
don't you remember when you and I used to get free tickets.
I don't want to work too and I want to watch it and just relax doing commentary
because I would get free tickets from the UFC.
This was like when the UFC first started going to Vegas and Eddie and I were
like,
dude,
the UFC is in Vegas.
This is crazy.
We got to go.
And Dana White,
somehow or another found out that I was a fan.
So he started sending me,
he's like,
hey,
we'll fly you out.
We'll give you free tickets.
I'm like,
fuck cash.
And so we started going and hanging out with them and I started doing commentary
because when we'd hang out,
but I'd be like,
have you ever seen saccharine?
You do watch pride.
What do you watch overseas?
Like have you,
if you've seen any of the shooto fights,
I'm like,
you gotta see this guy?
And I started telling him about this guy and that guy,
and he goes,
my favorite man,
saccharine love,
amazing,
amazing fights.
So I started talking to him about all these crazy fights and he had never heard
of.
And he's like,
do you want to do commentary on the next thing?
He knows like,
oh,
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to work.
And then boom,
I did first 18 shows for free.
I was sitting alone for a couple shows.
This all
all by myself,
the IP front row.
How did you come here to be by myself?
We saw some classic shit though.
If you really,
if you think about like the history of the sport,
like the history of boxing's an amazing history,
right?
But boxing from 1994 inboxing from 2017 eighteen's not incredibly different.
Yeah,
I mean there,
there's,
there definitely I think in all sports the fighters get better and better.
But you know,
you're talking about like Mike Tyson and Evander Holyfield.
Then you'd look at like what we got today for heavyweight.
It's like arguably as good if not better back then.
Right.
But not an MMA.
Let me see.
Giant leaps and changes in the sport.
I was telling somebody,
I said Jack Johnson has more in common with a modern heavyweight then and then a
mixed martial artist does with a mixed martial artist in the late nineties
you're 100% right by a lot.
You're 100% by a lot.
Yeah.
Jack Johnson might be able to be.
A lot of modern day and stuff.
He can compete of course.
Sure.
Yeah.
You take,
I mean you,
even if you go to teach him anything,
if you put him in there against some,
you know,
top 30 heavyweight that,
nobody knows.
Guys are like not that athletic,
not that good.
Kinda.
Okay.
He will fuck a lot of people up and then he would start making his way through
the ranks.
My favorite Jack Johnson story of all time,
he gets pulled over speeding the the,
the,
the cop says,
uh,
you're speeding.
It's 50 bucks.
He gives him a hundred bucks.
He goes,
I'm going to be coming back the same way in about an hour.
Awesome.
Cause I'm going to be speeding again,
bitch.
Yup.
And I'm going to be fucking a lot of white chicks,
unforgivable blackness.
If you haven't seen that documentary,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
He's one of the best routes of fight shirts.
The Galveston giant,
it's a roots of fight shirts with him.
When his wingspan
front of the shirt there was,
I used to box with a guy when I,
when I had a gym and he was our boxing guy and he had the history of the
heavyweight title memorized.
Do you give him any year?
And he would tell you who the heavyweight champion was at that time.
He's one of those guys.
I didn't memorize every president for what you in order when I was a history
major,
God damn,
this kind of thing,
you just never let go.
Once you have to do it,
you're,
you're screwed.
Right.
You don't want to unlearn.
Yeah.
You can't.
Once you,
once you,
once you're stuck
and the May in the 90s was fucking way different than put Internet,
no Internet.
The UFC was huge and there was no fucking internet and the first taste of MMA
and to get any kind of um,
uh,
fights,
you know,
like Brazilian fights,
you had to go to these specialty video stores,
like,
you know,
Japanese stores where they,
they,
you rent taped TV shows and they were the commercials they would take.
Yeah,
there was on the commercial you'd watch shooto and I'm on TV from Japan
placing a little Tokyo where I used to go a little Tokyo here in La and when I
was in college,
when I was at Ucla,
started doing Jujitsu and I should go in there and the guy didn't speak English
and I went to the front and I'm trying to explain to him what I'm looking for
because I knew I had to go to like a Japanese store and I literally said I sell
it since he'd understand me.
And I said,
look at him.
I said Ruminal Sato and he goes,
oh,
don't want to start on that.
And he points to this wall and it's just covered,
covered in Chucho and pride and pancreas and they it off TV.
And I went in there like every two days,
three more until I just knew all of them because you couldn't find them
anywhere.
You have Tokyo.
The the card for the video store was in Japanese.
I couldn't read it.
Yeah,
like today there was
Federico,
the pen panda and I sort of jump out of Raleigh.
Those are the two promoters in Brazil that valid Mecca,
fides and validators.
Surgill,
Bartow rally and Federico the panda with the two.
Dana White's down in Brazil in the nineties before the Internet.
And I remember my first taste of MNA news on the Internet,
uh,
was that um,
Todd white,
my training partner,
we're both purple belts.
He was a cartoon.
A cartoon is at Nickelodeon and at Nickelodeon data they had the internet there.
So when everyone was gone during lunch date we would,
we would do drills at Nickelodeon and their gem that an awesome gem.
How would drive down there and he would take his lunch in the gym and we would
do Jujitsu.
And then if there was like five or 10 minutes left up,
we would like sneak into the offices and go into the,
the Internet and all I wanted,
all I wanted to see was the Abu Dhabi combat club.
Remember that?
That was one of the first news.
There was the only place really that you were getting news from these Brazilian
shows.
It was a website for MMA.
Yeah,
dude,
Nma and the 90s was alive and well,
you know,
there was a heart,
it was a big hardcore movement,
but there was no internet.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
I mean,
Wayne and I were talking about last time,
you know,
weighing in on a bathroom scale and Soboba and I'll in the desert somewhere and
it's just,
you just wanted to do it.
You just,
you want it to be part of it.
You didn't,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to understand.
I got paid 150 bucks from my first fight or something and,
and you just,
well,
first one,
I didn't get bit neutral grounds.
I fought that new routes.
It was my first fight,
man.
You fight.
I fought somebody from a submission factory.
[inaudible] leary,
landless has hold camp and my coach was [inaudible] Huntington beach.
He called me and he goes,
he goes,
uh,
it was Friday.
And he goes,
what are you doing Sunday?
And I went,
nothing.
And he goes,
you want to fight?
I'm fighting in the back of it.
It was like in the back of a club,
someone and they'd set up a row.
Actually really big cage.
And I went,
yeah,
sure.
And they'd line us up against the wall and I was next to this dude and they
went,
you're about the same size,
you and him.
Like they literally lined us up and I was like,
how big you were,
cause they didn't have scale or anything and they go,
you and this dude.
And I went,
okay.
And I was a 13th bite at a 13 fights and I got in there and they said,
um,
all right,
it's two,
five minute rounds.
Because the rounds were all weird back then.
People don't remember.
It was like three,
three minute rounds,
two,
five minute rounds.
Well,
whatever,
you know,
can kiss a lot of times with two,
five minute rounds.
I don't know why.
So I get in there and I remember thinking to myself,
I didn't train for this.
I've been doing Jujitsu nine months.
Um,
so I'm just gonna give it everything and half of the first five minutes,
because I don't think I have any more of that.
And the moment I wonder what I'm going to do.
And the bell went off.
That dude fucking sprinted at me and I hit him and knocked him down and I got,
had been Fabiano as far side arm barred bro.
Oh 29 seconds.
And that was my first fight and I was like,
oh,
okay.
All right,
fine.
It was my first coach.
He was one of the famous our arm body armor.
He was a Brazilian hopeful like after Hoy's um,
every,
all Americans that were into Jujitsu,
we were,
we'd like to Brazilians more than
we were training in Jujitsu and we were white.
We would be on the Brazilian side in any NMA fight.
Cause you,
you,
you find out real quick that style is thicker than blood.
Yeah.
Nationality.
How about when the minute Tarro beat Bob?
Sapp you're right.
You out.
Yes.
Oh Shit.
Knee popped out.
Ooh.
Eddie Bartow has what I believe is probably a bucket handle tear of his meniscus
in his meniscus.
We'll pop out and it locks and we'll get you some ice mass.
Straighten it out.
Sure.
Alright.
Let me know if you need anything.
What do you do?
Do you pull on it to get it back?
I'm not asking him questions when I'm asking questions.
He's in so fucking,
he didn't go back.
It didn't go back.
Didn't go back.
He's in some pain.
Ooh,
real life folks.
In February.
Eddie,
you're supposed to get a knee surgery to fix this knee.
Do you ever have any knee surgeries?
Jimmy?
None.
Knock on wood.
Oh,
you're lucky.
Very,
very lucky.
I had three hernia surgeries.
Only surgery I've ever had.
Oh no shit.
Yeah.
Very Lucky Eddie had that.
Oh,
there you go.
There you go.
Back.
Whoa.
So is it pop back in place?
Fuck Ah,
Ooh.
Did that looked really painful?
Yeah,
it's back.
You're good.
That's good.
It's like the seventh time it's happening.
Check for you.
Ever seen this?
I was sitting,
I had my leg up like this.
I fucked up.
Can you pause this and bring this back?
I want you,
I want to play this video for you guys cause I,
I call this video the thirsty white people video like back this up.
This is one of them testosterone videos.
Thomas gimme,
some gimme,
some volume.
I'll get no,
take it from the beginning.
Good.
And hold that hall and uh,
yeah,
and give me some volume like pause it for a second.
Okay,
now give me some volume so we could all hear it.
This is the thirstiest white people video ever.
These white people are gawking about,
what's the gentleman's name?
Frank Thomas.
Frank Thomas has a big ass football player.
He's a baseball player.
Whatever the fuck he is,
whatever.
He had a bomb.
But here's the thing,
sorry.
Big Ass professional athlete.
Yes,
but happens to be an African American.
Listen to how thirsty these white people sound when they're talking about him.
Go ahead.
Play it.
No.
Okay.
Do it again so people can hear you got a too low.
Louder.
If that's her husband.
Hold on.
I'll turn it louder.
How's it going?
You look like you can still be playing off what?
I said.
Yeah.
Listen,
this part it's,
what's your secret?
Which my husband did.
I wish my husband did.
Jesus Christ.
New Jetta.
I take new genetics.
I wished my husband did.
She stared right next to him just begging for the crazy.
That dude is Steve White people commercial ever.
Oh,
that's a gay friend.
No,
she said or honk.
She said,
oh no,
that's her husband.
She's making them feel like shit.
Look at him and this guys.
Oh,
you're bench pressing and shit and throwing Dick and all the white chicks in the
gym.
Guaranteed.
How does he not,
how does he say no?
This literally back in that pussy up into a catapult munching it.
Adam.
I wish my husband did,
but he doesn't look.
It says smash.
See that in the texts,
the text message,
it says smash.
They're talking about smashing pussy.
That's what,
that's what dudes say when they say what happened?
Aw,
smashed it.
That's what they're saying.
It says that in the thing.
It says smash.
What are you smashing?
Yeah.
God Damn it.
That's a thirsty
white people commercial smashing.
You want to stop now and that's just what I'm curious about.
You then it work.
Is it effective?
I mean it might work.
Probably Bullshit.
It's not bullshit is the love that those white people,
well,
half of that black athlete.
Yeah.
That was crazy commercial.
Whoa.
More like a honk.
Like she says she's going to the hog in front of her husband and then the other
lady is saying,
I wish my husband like,
Whoa,
slow down,
thirsty white people.
Slow the fuck down.
Well there's a replay or your boy.
Yeah.
Mek and come out with Mon.
Interesting.
Oh see right there.
That's spinning back fist.
He got tagged,
showed some good goddamn wrestling now.
It all entertaining fights to it's good all around.
Yeah,
it was a very good card.
Very,
I'm sorry.
Very good card.
Very interesting.
Okay.
Um,
I'm so curious about next weekend.
I mean that's only six days away from today.
Yeah.
I,
I'm so curious.
What do you think about the switch?
You guys were talking about the wrestling move,
the switch switching you think,
how important do you think that is to train in an MMA god,
it was huge.
I think it's very important to know for sure.
For sure.
It's just one of many components,
but it seems like an important move.
You'd think you'd see it more Ma Russell's do it all at time.
Wrestlers in MMA.
Yeah.
I know it's a wrestling move.
But an NMA,
you'd think you'd see it more.
You see a once every four years it's actually executed all the way through.
Yeah.
Right.
You don't see it that I didn't see it at all until a few years ago.
It was like Russell's just started doing it.
Yeah.
Like you would think you would see it all the goddamn time.
Hmm.
That's a good move.
So I just,
you know,
it's in our warmups and everything.
I just wanted your opinion.
Is it necessary?
You never seen it.
I think it's okay.
I do.
Yeah.
I really gotta be right.
I teach you guys all the time.
I think it's great.
Personally,
I think it's getting mouth Camaros.
Mon Talking Mad Shit.
I wish I could have heard what you said.
Paul felt really beautiful.
Pocket Square and a nice watch.
Look at him.
Handsome.
That's a nice suit.
Looks good.
It's a big watch it again.
Low.
Can you wire it again?
You get to work.
You could wear the suit again.
Yeah.
As in think nobody,
they're all afraid to fight me cause Bruce Bumper has a different outfit every
show.
He can't.
He doesn't wear the same one.
Well let
me just tell you a David August
makes all the suits for the commentary team on the UFC.
He makes my suits and um,
he uh,
he tailors him to you perfectly.
See that one that's on Pol or if you see the ones on me,
I'm a slob man.
I would never bought those suits on my own.
I'm too stupid.
They had to bring somebody in.
But since then I had him make me some stuff in my personal life.
Might as well.
Yeah.
He,
I had him,
I hired him.
Make Damn Darrin tells number seven,
one fight with cowboy and he's number seven above Neil Magni,
which is crazy.
That's interesting.
Um,
but yeah,
so the UFC makes you a few suits.
I got a couple of different color suits.
Nice.
Like three or four different,
one sentence,
black shirt anymore.
Well,
I have black shirts,
but now I have like real close,
real dope.
Like an adult.
I never wear black shirts.
Why?
Because everybody,
I get so much shit every time I tell somebody I throw away,
I had black shirts because they go with everything.
I fucking throw them way for the people at home.
By the way,
Eddie Bravo outside.
As I pulled up,
fought,
I was,
Joe walked up to me like,
hey dude.
Oh Hey Jimmy.
And I was like,
he fucking thought I was,
and he goes,
I thought you were Joe Dude.
And I was like,
no.
He came in there with an old ass car.
Carbon fiber.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I don't wear fucking black shirt.
I'm so sorry.
What's fucked up is that you are bald before me.
I was fucking freaked out one sheet and,
but it's cool man.
It's all good.
Well that's all right.
No,
no.
It's just an illustration of the of the natural.
My mom got us confused one time.
I'm not even fucking joke.
Oh no,
that's right.
That's right.
I was at my mom's house.
She was making me dinner and I was going to watch you and sees a lot of times
where my mom's house,
she's an amazing cook.
She's Greek.
You guys will have to come over and get,
have dinner some time.
So we came,
I went to her house,
she's making me dinner.
Some were watching the UFC.
She turns around.
She goes,
oh,
this is one of yours.
No mom,
that's Joe Rogan.
And she goes,
she fucking Paul.
She goes,
man,
he looks like you.
It was like,
thanks mom.
I can't do shit fucking 50 times a day on the Internet.
I'm going to get this from my own mother.
But I still eat the food that,
but one of the things about you do,
you don't toot your own horn.
It's like your like universally respected thanking me with people that know the
sport,
you know,
which is why I was a campaign to get you hired by the UFC years ago.
I'm like,
this guy's the shit just stuffed.
I'm excited man.
I'm excited too.
For Big John.
I love it and I'm excited he got that Gig.
I hope that really works out well for them.
I think it's gonna be interesting.
I understand completely kind of the step.
And then I don't recall a referee ever doing Khan Academy.
He did affliction,
he did the first afflictions show.
But it's a different perspective.
He's seeing it from an angle that no fighter or coach is really going to see.
And so I
think it's great cause any,
you know,
any fighter is going to be compared to all the other fighters that do it.
A referee,
he's just going to have a different perspective.
And I think that's a good choice if he does it with John or if John does it with
Mike Goldberg and John are real good friends.
First show is Mike.
That's belief,
I believe.
Don't quote me on that,
but they were real good friends so that should just be real easy.
Yeah.
Mike's easy to work with.
He's easy to work with.
Uh,
Mara was to both guys were easy to work with.
They're very different,
but both guys were easy to work with.
Man.
I was,
I was impressed with both of them.
Honestly.
Mike's Mike's a sweetheart.
The,
we need more work for a lot of guys,
but what,
what for what we do,
there's not a lot of guys that do it.
You know,
there's Paul Felder who I think does a fucking phenomenal job and I would have
loved to listen to him tonight if we weren't yapping.
But uh,
he,
he does a great job.
He has a smooth,
smooth guy,
very smooth.
I think Dan Hardee does a great job.
Um,
you know,
Brian Stan was one of my favorites.
I was bummed out when Brian left.
Yeah.
He,
he prepared better than anybody.
Brian,
Stan would pull out shed about training and all these different weird things
that you didn't know about preparation and other things that fighters do that
this guy did that was unusual and you're like,
whoa.
His preparation was top of the food chain.
So fulltime job people,
people don't get that,
you know,
in terms of like,
um,
you know,
uh,
when I'm not doing commentary,
I'm studying fights all the time because I'm not just watching am I got to sit
there and study them,
which is a totally different job.
What's funny is Joan fulltime job,
shit,
I'm speaking to myself.
Joe would just walk on and just karate,
but the,
no preparation.
Maybe a couple of thoughts,
couple notes,
but he wasn't preparing at all.
That's what it was.
It was hilarious.
It's like it's too easy.
Well,
it's all the things I do live.
If you think about how much stand up I do live,
then how much podcasts I do live before the podcast.
True.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the thing was they,
they wanted to have like some sort of planned out interaction between,
like that's one of the things that people would freak out about.
Like when we would do the beginning of the fight and gold were bolt.
Goldberg would say like Matt Hughes Fights Frank Trig for the UFC welterweight
title.
You know,
and this is an important fight.
He would hit,
I didn't know what the fuck I was gonna say.
I didn't know what he was going to say.
I didn't know what I was going to say.
I had no idea.
But I knew about the fight.
So my point was like,
hey,
it's better to be in the moment and really care about this fight and care about
what I think is going to happen and not have anything planned out.
I just wanted to be able to go,
this is what's critical in this fight and we're going to know early on whether
or not,
you know the fight is going to go one way or other based on a couple of
parameters.
And I would just go into those things and then after would it be over?
But like,
whoa.
But I tell,
I tell new PPC for you,
man,
nobody.
I told him he's the of
Cherry for Emma May.
Are you kidding me?
100% but,
but,
but what I,
what I tell people don't write down.
You'll think about what did I write down rather than the APP.
I tell people I go,
never play by play.
Do of course,
but I go color.
Don't write down notes or don't write down.
Here's what I'm going to say.
Because you'll start thinking about what you wrote down and you'll sell fake and
you'll sound fake.
It doesn't work.
Have a couple of bullet points in your head.
You know what you want to hit,
just know the two bullet points and you'll get through the open and it opens.
You know,
I think the two most 15 seconds,
the two most important things are you've got to actually care like that.
That isn't,
this has to be important to you.
Like when like Francis,
like I'm thinking about Francis and Steve Bay all fucking day.
I'm going to think about them all day tomorrow.
I'm going to think about if I'm bored and I'm in the middle of doing something
else,
I'm going to like,
what the fuck is gonna Happen next Saturday night?
Yeah.
So you've got to care.
It has to mean something to you and you have to know what you're talking about.
So you have to understand the sport,
you have to have a deep knowledge in it,
you have to really care.
And then it should just sort of work itself out.
Like if you've thought about it and you like,
okay,
here's what's going to happen.
Steve Bay's got to get the clinch.
He's got to figure out a way to get,
he doesn't want to stand on the outside with that guy.
The guys got these crazy long arms and you can't make a mistake.
One Punch puts you into orbit so you have to,
you have to be real careful with your closing the distance you got to click and
then I,
I think if,
if you go into it that way,
if you really understand fighting and you really care about what's going on,
it's just a matter of expressing yourself.
The two things that separate the men from the boys in commentary and I'm like,
this is,
this is the honest truth to me is number two,
and I will always text like you are antique or something.
When there are a lot of knockouts early in a fight,
I'll be like,
how's it going?
Because that's when it's like we have to fill all this time because you
understand the TV is they've,
they've booked a two hour TV show or through our paper,
whatever it is,
they got to fill x amount of minutes period.
Doesn't matter what happens.
So they either use fights that they've already used or Jimmy get up and
interview this fight and we need five minutes like right now.
So that's when the tap dance and happens is a lot of early,
not guts.
You have to fill a lot of time.
That's tough.
The second one is when you have a 25 minutes snooze fest and you're going,
oh,
I got to think of some.
Those are the two parts that are really channel we are talking about hard
interviews are,
but in terms of in commentary,
those two are tough when there are those early knockouts or long boring coming
to for fights that you have never heard of.
The fighters,
just the whole car was just a bunch of guys.
Rookies back in 2001 2002 just and man it was,
it wasn't fun.
25 fights in a fucking nightmare.
It used to be all fucking day.
Gladiator challenged Eddie Jr three member paid more,
nine to two 10 write me off.
I got the 200 bucks a fight in the fucking thing.
Do you remember the Hitman show where they pretended they'd fight?
God,
Bob Ballou and chill.
But there was real fights.
There were real fights,
but they were like,
hey,
we're filming a show starting the beginning.
It's fake.
So they got around the MMA rules by saying that it was like fake.
It's a famous movie.
It's a famous thing here in California for the listeners who weren't around MMA
wasn't legal.
So what they did is that they pretended they were shooting a movie and they the
the,
do you remember the,
the cards for the fight said like Hitman,
the movie?
Yes.
Do you remember that?
And on the back and had the fight card on it and it was a real fight card,
but they pretended they were filming a movie.
And so the cop showed up and said,
oh yeah,
then who wins the fights if this is fake?
And they,
that's why that night they just chose winners even though it didn't matter who
won.
And so for a while,
those people had goofy records until they eliminated.
And this is a famous cal.
Do you remember that?
The cop showed up and they had to like,
oh yeah,
this is fake chill wins or whatever.
I forget who won.
But they just raised his hand and even though he didn't win and so te,
so the cops wouldn't when bust everybody.
But that's,
yeah,
the famous Hitman show hit man the movie.
I remember that crazy back in the day,
dude,
back in the day.
Now listen,
we should get,
we got to wrap this up,
but um,
I just want to say that it's been real cool to be friends with you all these
years while you were working for Bella tour.
It always meant a lot to me that you and I were never weird even though we were
both doing the same job for other organizations were both really cool.
I got you tickets to UFC before we hung out a bunch of times.
He did the podcast a bunch of times and we would text back and forth.
All the title fights we're going on.
I would text him like crazy Bela Tarr fights are going on.
He would text me when crazy UFC fights are going on.
So like during the fight,
sometimes I text and Jimmy we'd be going back and forth.
It meant a lot to me that we were tight.
It did.
And it means a lot to me now that you're at the UFC.
I love it.
Well,
I,
I wouldn't be there without you.
I wouldn't.
And,
and,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm happy everybody knows that.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
it's,
it's meant a lot to me that,
that you didn't,
you reached out to me when I first left belter and you said,
keep your head up,
man.
You're,
you're the best.
And I didn't know you knew who I was and that's where things started.
And it was a first time I realized,
man,
people outside this bubble actually have any idea who I am and you didn't have
to do that.
And I,
it's meant a lot for years and I'm just thrilled that it finally worked out and
one in the same spot,
man.
I'm so,
you're an amazing dude,
man.
I really appreciate your mad and you're really fucking good.
Thank you.
It means a lot to me because I'm a fan.
You know,
I like,
I like watching fights and you call them.
Fantastic.
Thanks man.
I appreciate that.
Any problem?
You're pretty beautiful too.
You're awesome too.
Heady.
Like your face looks so amazing.
Is You not drinking?
When are you getting your knee surgery?
That's a good question.
You said February,
Tony's got a fight coming up,
so I'm going to wait till after that's over.
Oh,
did they schedule something?
What the F five for Tony?
We,
he's gonna.
They're working on something.
Oh,
okay.
So you wouldn't be able to move.
You heard it here first.
You just let something out of the bag on.
Tony is a fighter.
He's always working on a new fight,
so if you have your knee fucked up,
you just won't be able to demonstrate techniques.
Is that what it is?
If I have,
if I think I'm going to be on crutches for four weeks or something,
no.
Okay.
See,
I went to a party five days after my surgery.
I was crutches.
Okay,
good.
I just put a knee brace on the days afterwards.
I've never had ACL surgery,
so I was just thinking maybe like four weeks crutches.
If you get a cadaver graft,
it's so noninvasive.
It's fucking amazing.
Here.
Patel is the best.
No,
I've had both the,
the cadavers the best.
The problem with the cadaver is it's getting,
some people say,
Nah,
I've never heard that.
I mean,
it might happen to Benji radic he got to cut back,
but I think he just got an infection.
I think I know exactly what happened because the doctor,
the knee doctor that did it,
he,
I know him.
He's my doctor.
He said that was the last time I did a cadaver because it got infected and it
was really bad.
So,
um,
ever since then he stopped doing cadavers.
He just sticks to Patella.
I have both.
This one's Patella,
this one's cadaver.
This one was way quicker.
Healing a way less invasive.
And neither one of them give me problems today.
But I think,
uh,
I think if I had to do it again,
I do cadaver.
Hmm.
Interesting.
I'll look into it.
I also use a thicker tendon because they used the Achilles tendon,
these big fat rope.
The stick,
that bad boy in there,
it's 150% stronger than your natural ACL.
Damn.
Maybe I need to do that.
I would do with it 100%.
I would do it if you want.
My Guy Gettleman who did both my knees,
he's amazing.
He just hit my buddy shoulder too.
He's amazing.
And he's out here.
He's a,
he's actually Simi Valley.
Anything.
He has a place in Beverly Hills too.
He does a lot of pro athletes can't do shit til after that fight.
So it's going to be a couple months.
But if you,
if you just did it,
um,
it did the surgery,
you would still be able to coach them.
You just wouldn't be able to do certain moves.
And maybe you could bring someone like Marvin or you know,
one of your best guys.
Yeah.
You know what?
You're right.
I don't think you should put it off.
I'm looking at a whole different way now.
Yeah,
I should just fucking do it.
Let's do it.
Just do it because that's six months that'll take to rehab.
It happens before you know it,
but if you put it off,
that's six months happens before you know it too and all of a sudden six months
later you still have a fucked up neat and you haven't gotten the surgery.
It just went out on air.
Yeah,
can get that shit fixed,
get that shit fixed.
Cause look like it was going to pop back in the last two times it happened.
It was really hard to pop back in and I'm thinking,
man,
when if it gets stuck like this shit,
you won't be able to roll hard for six months,
but the reality is you'll be able to do a lot of stuff before then,
especially when you're showing your drilling and just showing there's no
resistance.
Yeah.
You'll be able to do a lot pretty quick.
Songs is no resistance on your name.
You'll be able to do a lot like three months in and you'll be doing,
I'm sure you'd be doing a ton of Rehab.
You'll be on the ball with that shit.
You know,
you're,
you're going to be,
you're going to be very,
yeah,
very disciplined to get back to work.
I hear you.
Dot.
All right.
Uh,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Jimmy Smith.
Thanks for doing this,
brother.
Welcome aboard.
We'll love you.
Love you too,
Eddie Bravo.
Love you too.
I'm releasing combat Jujitsu worlds one.
It happened about a month,
a half ago on my youtube tomorrow morning.
Um,
it's free now.
Don't miss it.
Beautiful.
And it,
ah,
the Youtube was just Eddie Bravo.
Yes.
Beautiful twist her addy.
I think.
Okay.
People find it.
They'll find it.
All right folks.
Uh,
tomorrow I've got a double header.
So,
uh,
we started with John Danaher at 8:00 AM sued.